Moin Leute
Muss mal kurz meine vm anmachen
Ich guck jetzt raus nee
Ich muss aber trotzdem mal meine vm anmachen damit dass ich euch gleich was zeigen kann
Vielleicht wisst ihr da nämlich was zu ja wusste ja im
Wusste ja im discord keiner deswegen frage ich jetzt hier im stream noch mal
die
Anzeige von meinem kubernetes zeug ist verbuggt das sollte da eigentlich gar nicht stehen
das muss ich noch mal auskommentieren das ist irgendwie broken
noch mal kurz update
Nein nein ich gehe auch nicht zu kick
Dachte mir das ist ganz guter titel um den stream zu starten einfach mal
weil
Seriously das ist noch nicht mal clickbait
Wir machen nichts anderes in den streams als reden
So und zwar ich muss euch mal was fragen chat wir wissen ja dass der chat massive high iq ist und umso mehr leute prime
Subscribed haben umso mehr iq hat der chat das heißt
Ich frage euch jetzt mal was
Haben wir doch schon gutes beispiel gerade also guckt mal wenn ich wenn ich wenn ich sowas hier habe ja ja super habe jetzt kein
Wenn ich
Mal angenommen ich habe sowas das ist jammer das ist egal ihr müsst nicht wissen ihr müsst nicht wissen um was es geht ja
So also mal angenommen hier ich habe ich habe einen jammer pfeil ja so
Und ich habe jetzt hier sowas stehen wie was weiß ich konfig so
Und jetzt und jetzt mache ich den multiline jammer multiline jammer geht ja so hier bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla so
Und jetzt habe ich die frage an euch chat
Wie kann ich jammer sagen dass ich das so einrücken will
Weiß das irgendjemand weil zum beispiel zum beispiel wenn ich da jetzt eine datei inklude guckt mal
wo bloß dort falls
So nehmen wir mal an ich habe hier diese datei ist vollkommen egal so und die die will ich jetzt die will ich jetzt
Inkluden in hier an der stelle in meinem jammer pfeil so da muss ich die zwangsläufig zweimal einrücken
Ich will die aber nicht zweimal einrücken weil mich das abfuckt wie kann ich jammer sagen dass das inline also dieses dieses
embedded multiline string ding
dass das ohne
Einrückung funktioniert wie mache ich das du kannst hier irgendwie plus davor machen bringt nichts du kannst dings davor machen bringt nix du kannst
null davor schreiben bringt nix
Ich weiß nicht ob das geht wenn ich das wüsste müsst ihr mich dann fragen wenn ich weiß wie es funktioniert
Was mit nee
Das ist ja blöd da muss ich ja die datei von hand anders formatieren
ne
Das kommt nicht in frage die datei muss 1 zu 1 copy pastebar bleiben aber das geht nicht also was ich was ich dachte ist was
Ich dachte ist man kann einen sogenannten
Intendation guide oder irgendwie sowas einfügen dass er sagt das was jetzt danach kommt hat null einrückung aber das funktioniert nicht
und
Der
Chat im discord wusste auch nicht wie das funktioniert
Du kannst das file mit helm ja inkluden
Aber was ist wenn ich templates drinne haben will gehen wir mal von aus dass hier wenn ein template
Heckel template gedöns dann kann ich nicht einfach inkluden weil dann muss ich ja on the fly templaten
Wie würde ich das machen?
Also rein rein mit jammer funktioniert das glaube ich nicht
Guck jetzt mal rein was der progress chat sagt aber die haben auch keine ahnung
Aus welt 4 ist raus oder was
ist das so
Was ist denn fx twitter was habe ich denn da gerade kopiert was ist leute
Was ist ff was ist fx twitter
du kannst
Ja inkluden bringt ja nicht ich muss ja template abfragen also ich muss jetzt muss es ja templaten können kann man mit helm andere files
templaten außer jammer files
glaube nicht
Naja gut es hätte ja sein können dass ihr das wisst wie das funktioniert wenn ich ist auch nicht schlimm das heißt ich vermute einfach mal
es geht nicht
Mal kurz vor dem updaten und vor dem rebooten
Exzellenter white people happy background der ist gerade
oldschool max fps gucken auf youtube
Weiß nicht sag was mach mal einen vorschlag was was könnten wir brennen
Inklusive
Mal gucken
muss man mal schauen
Morgen neo wie im stream morgen bin ich wahrscheinlich viel zu kaputt soll ich noch kurz meine vm rebooten
Letzte woche hast du gesagt dass es sich nicht lohnt
nach der physik ausbildung einer wirtschaftsinformatik
Informatik kannst du mir sagen warum das habe ich doch letzte woche wenn ich das letzte woche gesagt habe ich das doch bestimmt auch
dabei gesagt oder
Da war ich da jetzt weiß ich überhaupt nicht mal was es dagegen letzte woche
Es macht sich also es lohnt sich wahrscheinlich aus dem grund nicht weil du einfach arbeiten gehen kannst und geld verdienst es sei denn
dich interessiert ist theoretisch im hintergrund ich meine das wirtschaft zeug wenn du wirtschaftsgraben machen willst da willst du eigentlich das also
Wenn ich technik interessiert dann brauchst du den wirtschaftsgramm nicht den wirtschaftsgramm wirtschaft informatik studieren eigentlich bloß die leute weil sie schiss vor mathe haben
Oder ist das anders
Also sprich wenn ich der theoretische hintergrund nicht interessiert den im mathe studium im informatik studium lernst kannst du jetzt einfach gleich geld verdienen gehen
Also warum willst du studieren gehen ja du hast theoretisch im durchschnitt höhere gehälter wenn du studiert hast was aber nicht zwangsläufig für dich im
Einzelfall zutreffen muss das ist so eine durchschnittssache also wenn wenn du
Dich auskennst und was auf die reihe kriegst kannst du jetzt auch schon fettkohle machen warum musst du dafür studieren gehen
Also ich glaube nicht dass ich die zeit rechnet in der aktuellen lage noch mal noch ein studium drauf zu setzen
Es sei denn es lohnt sich und dann weiß das ja schon wie lief der sprünge
habe ich noch nicht eingeplant hat kannst du uns viel mal einen slot programmieren was für ein ding
Du meinst die glücksspiel webseite
Oder was die frage ist wie die lage in zehn jahren ist das kann dir niemand sagen
ich persönlich gehe nicht davon aus dass ich das nennenswert also dass die
dass die nicht anforderung anforderung ist das falsche wort dass die
Begehrtheit kann man so nennen oder die
das verlangen trifft glaube ich ganz gut nach it experten
nennenswert zurückgeht in zehn jahren
Sagen was in zehn jahren ist kann dir keiner
Noch ein weiterer grund jetzt kohle zu verdienen oder anstatt erst noch mal fünf jahre zu studieren oder auch immer wie lange man da studiert
Wenn man nicht super fein fett ist nach drei jahre glaube ich oder
Aber helm benutzt go templates und nicht irgendwelches komisches javascript gedöns
string sehr gute idee
Oder was meinst du ich soll eine glücksspiel webseite programmieren das können wir nicht machen also wir können es ist es ist super simpel
Sowas zu bauen dass es vordergründig funktioniert ich glaube dass das insgesamt
Funktioniert und vor allem halt auch das ganze abrechnungssystem also ist das glaube ich schon eine relativ komplexe angelegenheit
Es muss ja vor allem im zweifelsfall auch
Ja wie es da gibt es ja irgendwelche gesetzlichen vorgaben die der erfüllen muss also du musst sicherlich als
Glücksspielseitenbetreiber in deutschland belegen können dass die
dass deine seite
Quasi auch glücksspiel also konform ist
also sprich dass du dass du auch
Dass du nicht einfach random wenn du siehst dass jemand gewinnt ihm dann eine andere karte ziehen lässt und sowas was ja einfach wäre für
den für den
Betreiber so einer seite was aber sicherlich nicht erlaubt ist so
Was ist an der slotmaschine so schwierig
Du hast irgendwie drei felder und darauf irgendwie zehn verschiedene dinger die angezeigt werden können
und du machst dann also vielleicht liege ich da jetzt auch komplett falsch aber
Macht das machst du nicht einfach random quasi vor aus einem der zehn
Pro pro pro feld und fertig
Ja es muss glück sein ja wenn es random ist dann ist es glück das ist ja das schöne an
randomness an randomness können es auch drei gewinne in folge sein
Oder oder 100 100
losses in folge wenn es doof läuft
deswegen muss man um
Das irgendwie statistisch alles belegen zu können immer relativ große versuchsreihen durchführen dass man wirklich belegen kann
Ob irgendwas random ist oder nicht also mit wir drücken dreimal drauf und dann ist gut
Will ich mich nicht so sehr darauf verlassen
Hast du eigentlich erfahrung mit kubernetes ja habe ich haben wir sogar schon im stream gemacht was willst du wissen wir müssen heute reden im stream
Ja heute würde den kram stream auf twitch und hat am ende wahrscheinlich mehr geld als vorher
Auf was sollte man sich spezialisieren beziehungsweise was lohnt sich
Leute ihr dürft nicht vergessen wenn ihr mich was fragen wollt schreibt er wo bloß im chat davor weil manchmal sehe ich nicht
Wenn gerade ein bisschen zu viel ist
Nice neues proxmox ok guck uns auch gleich an das habe ich mir heute schon angeguckt das hat glaube ich nicht das gebracht was ich was ich
wollte
Also auf was sollte man sich spezialisieren beziehungsweise was lohnt sich wenn man momentan in der physioausbildung ist naja ich würde mal sagen was interessiert
dich denn
Gibt es gibt es irgendwas was dich groß interessiert
Je nachdem wie lange machst du denn die ausbildung schon also wenn die ausbildung vielleicht schon das erste jahr oder so hinter dir hast
Da hast du doch vielleicht schon so eine grobe idee welcher bereich dich interessiert zum beispiel
Interessiert dich eher linux oder windows wenn es um admin geschichten geht
Und wenn du sagst windows
Dann kann ich zwar nicht verstehen aber ich denke jeder sollte das machen worauf er bock hat
Also es muss doch es muss doch irgendwelche themen geben die dich interessieren
eigene
Irc server da sind wir im jahr 2000 oder oder was was ist hier also ich kann ok ich kann dir ich kann dir folgendes raten
Ich kann also wenn du wenn du wenn du also das ist das beste was dir raten kann also wirklich ich kann jetzt nicht sagen
Exakt so dieses gebiet oder so ist toll ich kann ich kann dir eine sache raten aber die ist relativ individuell
benutzt die ausbildung dafür
So ein bisschen zu gucken was dir gefällt ich meine wenn du so it mensch mit leib oder komplett mit wie sagt man mit
haus und haar nehmen mit leib und leben oder keine ahnung durch und durch meine ich ja bist dann machst du ja sicherlich auch die
Ein oder anderen sachen außerhalb von der arbeit
Und mit leib und seele genau das das meine ich da machst du sich da guckst du doch sicherlich auch die ein oder anderen sachen
außerhalb von der arbeit an ich bin auf der arbeit ist es halt immer so
Da muss jetzt nicht zwangsläufig immer dass also das automatisch dabei sein was du richtig geil findest
Weil vielleicht macht ja deine arbeit nicht das also wenn du in einem windows laden bist
und
dich interessiert hauptsächlich jetzt irgendwie
Cloud containerisierung kubernetes linux was auch immer irgendwas dann wirst du da wahrscheinlich nicht glücklich werden benutzt die ausbildung guckt dir ja guckt dir
alle möglichen sachen an achte mal drauf was du freiwillig daheim machst weil die sachen die du freiwillig daheim machst weil sie dir spaß machen
sind höchstwahrscheinlich die sachen auf die du dich konzentrieren solltest
weil
es gibt da so einen wie soll man sagen so sich selbst refreshen den kreislauf und zwar
Angenommen du machst jetzt du stehst voll auf irgendwie server automatisierung und
Cloud
Oder sagen wir mal nehmen was machen wir mal ein bisschen was simpleres ja sagen also du stehst jetzt voll drauf irgendwelche
Linux server automatisierung auf linux server zu machen
oder oder vielleicht
containerisierung für für irgendwelche anwendungen und dann
Gucken wie man das möglichst hochverfügbar anbinden kann was auch immer kann ja alles mögliche sein achte mal drauf was du freiwillig machst was dich interessiert
weil es gibt so den selbsterlauf selbst selbst erhaltenen kreislauf und zwar
wenn du weißt was dir gefällt
dann
kannst du dich
besser also wenn du dich damit auseinandersetzt mit was was dir gefällt dann lernst du es einfacher
und wirst besser da drin und umso besser du in dem bereich bist
umso wahrscheinlicher ist es dass du einen job in dem bereich kriegst wo du auch ordentlich
Kohle mitverdienst weil leute die 0815 im active directory zwei felder zwei zwei fenster
Oder zweimal auf weiter finish klicken können die gibt es wie sand am meer leute die sich damit wirklich im detail auskennen
Und vielleicht auch irgendwelche powershell automate ich rate jetzt ich habe von windows kein plan ja
Irgendwelche powershell automatisierung machen können da sieht es schon ganz anders aus im linux umfeld ist es ähnlich
Leute die mal ubuntu in irgendeiner vm installiert haben die findest du auch gut vielleicht nicht ganz so viele wie für windows aber
Die findest du auch an an allen ecken und enden
Leute die beispielsweise dann also wir machen jetzt mal mehrere mehrere stages ja
Leute also leute die ubuntu installiert haben einer vm und bisschen basic linux können findest du in jeder ecke
Welchen den du sagen kannst hey meine anwendung ist gerade abgekackt
Guck mal dass du raus findest woran das liegt da gibt es schon deutlich weniger weil es kann in alle möglichen liegen ja es ist
Nicht immer eine färbe es ist nicht immer eine vollgelaufene festplatte oder abgezogenes kabel oder sowas in der richtung
Es kann auch teilweise ganz abgedrehte geschichten sein wo du dich dann im zweifelsfall auch richtig auskennen musst
Ja vielleicht sind irgendwelche limits zu sehr zu zu zu zu gering gesetzt da gibt es zum üben richtig schöne seite was linux angeht
Und zwar das hier das ist eine übung seite für angehende linux
admins im endeffekt mit problemen auf linux servern von einfach bis teilweise echt nicht einfach also
Von easy bis schwer aber manche sind wirklich wirklich nicht einfach die sind die sind
Richtig durch durch die brust ins auge
so
Und umso mehr du dich mit den themen auseinandersetzt auf die du bock hast umso besser wirst du und umso höher sind die chancen dass
Du da drin arbeiten kannst
und das weiterhin machen was du gerne machst und
nach zehn jahren bist du dann
richtige experte auf dem gebiet
Was sich heutzutage echt auszahlt wie gesagt leute die ein bisschen ubuntu installieren können gibt es an jeder ecke
Leute den du sagen kannst guck mal meine anwendung kackt immer ab guck mal bitte nach woran das liegt gibt schon viel viel weniger
Und und das steigert sich das steigert sich halt immer weiter und umso weiter du ins in detail das gucken musst ja
Wenn du wenn du irgendjemanden es trace lock zeigst dass der dann ungefähr weiß was da passiert oder
Dann auch irgendwie in den tcp da macht guckt okay wie ist jetzt hier die kommunikation und dann noch vielleicht weiß
Dass im zweifelsfall se linux da noch mit rein spielt wenn was nicht geht da wird schon deutlich komplizierter
Letztendlich ist alles was du dir in der it anguckst letztendlich ein fast ohne boden und es geht immer noch irgendwie ein bisschen tiefer
und weiter
Und ich glaube an sich ist es nicht verkehrt wenn man sich in einem breiten gebiet
Ganz okay auskennt aber wenn man so seine schwerpunkte hat
Also guckt euch mal mein stream an im meines wir haben alles mögliche schon gemacht im stream und wer es sich glaubt kann in das
Archiv reingucken wir haben alles mögliche schon gemacht ja von okay wir haben sogar ich wollte gerade sagen außer windows das stimmt nicht wir haben
Sogar windows server schon mal im stream gemacht wir haben linux on prem gemacht wie die coolen leute das nennt linux in der cloud
orchestrierung mit kubernetes container gebaut
Angefangen von docker mit docker compose wir haben irgendwelche cloud geschichten mit load balancing aufgebaut wir haben
microcontroller programmiert wir haben
Einen motor angesteuert für mein für mein hoftor
Irgendwelche sachen programmiert von frontend bis back end javascript verschiedene frameworks
.net go alle möglichen dinger schon gemacht ja also
Ich würde sagen ich würde sagen es ist nicht verkehrt sich möglichst breit auszukennen
Aber so ein paar schwerpunkte zu haben ist auch nicht verkehrt
Und am besten halt was was dir worauf worauf du bock hast weil ansonsten ist ja eher paints champ mit der zeit
Was ist denn worauf vielleicht hast du schon was geschrieben ich muss jetzt gerade mal drunter runter gucken ich habe keine ahnung
traceability ist auch so ein geiles buzzword aktuell
Was willst du wahrscheinlich kommt es ein bisschen darauf an was du tracen willst
Also für irgendwelche time series datenbanken gibt es ja mittlerweile schon
Spezialisierte dinger sowas wie influx db zum beispiel muss ich aber ehrlich sagen habe ich nie im großen stil betrieben
Man kann allerdings man kann allerdings postgres prinzipiell für nahezu alles nehmen vielleicht nicht absolut top in jedem gebiet
Aber du kriegst im postgres alles irgendwie halbwegs abgebildet du kannst im postgres time series datenbanken speichern du kannst postgres als simplen
document store key value store verwenden als relationale datenbank als fulltext search als
Ja teilstring search für für autocomplete und alles mögliche
Also in der regel bist du je nachdem wenn du es sei denn du hast was ganz ganz spezielles bist du mit postgres prinzipiell immer nicht
verkehrt
Aber je nachdem was du tracen willst was du machen willst kannst natürlich umgedreht sein wenn es dir zum beispiel um metrics
Ummetriken geht da ist natürlich prometo ist ganz vorne mit dabei
In letzter zeit ist für application metrik neber prometo ist beziehungsweise
Kollekten vielleicht schon mit prometo ist aber
neber prometo ist exporter direkt in die anwendung integrieren ist noch
Wie ist das app matrix?
Ist das heißt das glaube ich
Ist in letzter zeit recht recht beliebt die open metrics wie nennen sich diese dieses ding das ist ja auch nur eine auch nur eine
Open apm kann das sein
Apm ja dass das kann sein
Es ist auch noch ist auch noch angesagt das ist die frage was du open telemetry das meine ich
sehr viel du hast
Ich weiß nicht wie man nicht auch du das meine ich das meine ich jesper genau ja das meine ich
open to military
telemetry kann sie aussprechen
Also schreibt kannst du mal in chat schreiben und denkt an entwurfen sonst sehe ich es gleich wenn ich runter gescrollt habe
Was du eigentlich tracen willst wenn es um kubernetes sachen geht dann guckt dir mal sowas wie linker d zum beispiel an als service mesh
Da kannst du wenn du also wenn du das benutzt kannst du relativ easy mtls machen das ist das erste schon mal nice
Wenn du inter cluster verschlüsselte kommunikation haben willst und dass die anwendung das kann und du hast ein integriertes dashboard
Wo du dir auch wunderbar angucken kannst was kommuniziert gerade miteinander
Und linker d einfach nur gibt tausend andere weiß ich chat geht was ihr so für service meshes hauptsächlich benutzt
Aber linker d hat den scham dass es easy ist vom setup her
Ja das sieht dann sieht da zum beispiel so aus guckt mal ich zeige euch zwar
Ja grafana integration geht natürlich auch
Aber ja guckt so sieht das gibt es da vielleicht eine demo von
Demo
Ich meine wir haben es in zwei minuten in einem cluster installiert aber das machen wir jetzt nicht
Ja, da kannst du relativ einfach sehen was machen deine ganzen container was kommuniziert wo gibt es gerade störungen zwischen zwischen irgendwelchen services
Wo gehen pakete verloren weil der back weil es back endlich erreichbar ist kannst du alles mögliche angucken das richtig gut
Also vor allem ist es easy aufzusetzen
Wenn du sowas wenn du sowas tracen willst weiß ich nicht was du tracen willst
Im endeffekt kannst du auch alles nach grafana exportieren guckt mit linker d kriegst du aus kriegst du out of the box sowas zum beispiel
Klickst du ein deployment an für den service in kubernetes da zeigt er dir automatisch an
Quasi
Vom wie der traffic läuft hinten halt bis zu den back end system und hier siehst du zum beispiel auch okay bei dem service gibt es
gerade probleme und das schlägt sich so auf die ganze anwendung durch
Du meinst du meinst luftfeuchtigkeitssensor ja ich habe ich habe mehrere luftfeuchtig komme ich gleich zu ich muss erst mal chat gefährlich abarbeiten
Den gambling champ machen wir als nächstes
Nee, das ist halt das wo ich denke das darfst du rechtlich gesehen nicht
Einprogrammieren in deutschland bei einer glücksspielseite die in deutschland betreibst ich denke dass eine glücksspielseite durchaus glücksspiele anbieten darf wo du
statistisch gesehen
selbstverständlich als betreiber
Im durchschnitt halt oder auf lange sicht gewinn machst du darfst allerdings nicht deine gewinnspiele manipulieren so nach dem motto
Fakt er hat jetzt in der slot machine schon zwei sterne
Denn der dritte wird auf jeden fall kein stern und sowas das darfst du wahrscheinlich nicht machen
immer nudeln mit lax
Ihr kennt mich immer nudeln mit lax ja bei csgo skin seiten
Weiß halt niemand wie das im hintergrund funktioniert also wie random das wirklich ist
Gerade wenn die seiten halt was weiß ich in wo werden solche seiten betrieben auf den sie schellen oder so
Dann würde ich mich da ja
Ich würde mich nicht dadurch täuschen lassen dass irgendwelche influencer
Immer super hype die krassesten skins ziehen wahrscheinlich sind die beteiligt an der seite
Okay, wir betreiben in der zukunft einen eigenen cluster
Ich habe mich die letzte woche stark damit auseinandergesetzt eine lösung auf base von cef und rke 2
Ich bin gerade überlegen ist dass das was früher rocket war
Wenn die rancher ja war früher ist das rocket genau
Hast du eine meinung oder habe ich die box da habe ich eine meinung dazu und zwar meine meinung ist
Wenn ihr das noch nie gemacht habt betreibt den kram nicht selbst
Und das meine ich ernst das ist nicht so nach dem motto alles in die cloud verlagern oder bei irgendeinem anderen anbieter
Weil weil das angesagt ist zurzeit ich kann euch nur empfehlen wenn ihr gar keine ahnung davon habt
Weil so wie es ja aussieht betreibt kein kubernetes cluster selbst und und schon gar kein cluster storage
Beziehungsweise zf ist ja kein richtiger cluster storage zf ist ja wie nennt man das distributed
storage nodes
Storage ding keine ahnung was die selbst sagen es ist ja kein cluster file system es ist ja also es ist kein richtiges
Cluster file system wie man es kennt das sind einzelne nodes am ende kommt halt doch ein cluster file system raus
eine verteilte speicherlösung genau
verteiltes datei system
Ja also meine empfehlung ist tatsächlich sucht euch einen cloud anbieter
Wo ihr das betreiben könnt macht es nicht selbst wenn ihr davon keine ahnung habt du dreht das ist richtig du drehst durch
vor allem das schlimme ist du schießt dir in fuß aber mit delay
Du machst das so wie du es nach 1 2 wochen kenntnis kubernetes sieht auf den ersten blick simpel aus
Ich weiß ich also aus meiner sicht sieht die kubernetes lernkurve ungefähr so aus
Und wenn ihr jetzt sagt sieht auf den ersten blick nicht simpel aus dann versuche ich das mal zu erklären
Also die kubernetes lernkurve ist krass super super nice gemalt
Wird ja immer besser
Pega aim in pain also die
Du denkst erst mal so nach dem motto ach easy easy ist überhaupt kein problem und irgendwann stellst du fest
Oh shit oh shit oh shit das ist ja viel komplizierter als ich gedacht habe
und
Ja irgendwann irgendwann geht es dann noch geht es dann langsam wieder hoch ja so das ist so das ist so die die kubernetes lernkurve weil
Das problem dabei ist
Das ist das ist nicht das mag bei allen it sachen vielleicht
So wie soll man sagen so in der essenz oftmals ähnlich sein
Aber kubernetes ist ein ganz ganz besonders krasses beispiel weil man guckt sich ein kubernetes tutorial an
Da beschäftigen die sich so mit den eingebauten sachen du machst ein deployment
Du legst ein service an du stellst ein das ist cluster ip note ip
Du legst vielleicht mal ein volume an auf irgendeinem nfs share oder sowas so die tutorials über die eingebauten kubernetes funktion sieht eigentlich
Ist zwar erst vielleicht ein bisschen einschüchternd aber nachdem man sich da ein zwei wochen mit auseinandergesetzt hat denkt man sich so
Ja ist doch eigentlich gar kein ding ja das höchste der gefühle was man dann macht ist mal so einen port skalieren
Von irgendwie einem replika auf fünf und denkt sich eigentlich ist das ja gar kein ding
So und jetzt ist das der punkt wo man sich mit delay in fuß schießt weil man eigentlich gar keine ahnung hat in was das ganze ausartet am endeffekt
Weil das komplizierte an kubernetes ist nicht so sehr
Die eingebauten funktionalitäten in den parallel dateien zu schreiben sondern
das gesamte ökosystem
Und zusatztools die da dran hängen um aus den eingebauten funktionalitäten
Die man will das ist das eigentlich schwierige du musst dich erst mal in 50.000 tools auseinandersetzen
Und wie so wie es bei im kubernetes umfeld ist es gibt für alles mindestens 15 verschiedene tools
Und du hast am anfang gar keine ahnung wenn du die hilfeseiten anguckst was jetzt eigentlich ich meine seriously machen wir mal ein beispiel für ja
Stellt euch mal vor es gibt irgendjemand bei eurer wir nehmen wir nehmen etwa die
Ideerie
Wir haben da so ne doofe anforderung oder aus irgendwelchen krüppen brauchen wir das sorgt mal dafür
dass die dass die kommunikation im cluster verschlüsselt läuft
Das ist gar keine architecture
ccd meine mann wird das auf jeden vägab identified resposta
dann geht dann k buying man test in d Fortress
Die Cerast is that ich bittecheers
Das ist jetzt hier also wo es das gute ist
im Cluster verschlüsselt läuft. Das ist gar keine allzu weit hergeholte Anforderung je
nachdem was ihr für wen und was ihr für Anwendungen betreibt. Also sprich, dass selbst
innerhalb des Clusters, selbst wenn da jemand Zugriff drauf bekommt und theoretisch was
auch immer da abgreifen könnte, dass die Kommunikation zwischen den Anwendungen im
Cluster verschlüsselt ist. So und dann kommt ihr irgendwann auf die Idee, achja wir brauchen
ein MTLS und wie macht man ein MTLS mit einem Service Mesh? Und jetzt geht's los. Ich weiß
nicht, ob es da eine gescheite Übersicht überhaupt gibt. Okay, wir machen was anderes. Also, okay.
Es gibt bei weitem mehr als drei. Lol. Es gibt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 100. Naja gut,
vielleicht 10 Relevante oder so. Ja, da hast du Istio, du hast Linkerd, du hast Anteos,
oder wie das heißt. Das ist quasi Istio von Google. Du hast Konsul, du hast total viel
Zeit. Wie heißt denn das Ding? Ah, ich kann mich nicht genau erinnern. Envoy, wobei Envoy ist nur
eine Proxy. Dann hast du die Auswahl, okay, du musst dich jetzt entscheiden zwischen zehn
verschiedenen Lösungen und du weißt noch nicht mal, was auf der Hilfeseite eigentlich genau drauf
steht. Und solche Dinger. Dann wird's langsam wir. Und dazu kommt, dass du nicht nur deine
eigentlichen Kubernetes-Anwendungen und vielleicht so Management-Sachen, die du machen willst,
selbst betreiben musst. Nein, du musst den Cluster selbst betreiben. Also, du musst auch die Control-Knoten-Team,
musst die Control-Plane betreiben, wie man das nennt. Also, du musst dich auch um Updates und
sowas kümmern. Ganz ehrlich, wenn ihr das noch nicht gemacht habt und wenn ihr nicht mindestens
drei, vier Leute habt, die langjährige Kubernetes-Erfahrung haben und ihr wirklich auch keinen
triftigen Grund habt, selbst vom Scratch. Das geht doch schon mal damit los. Das geht doch ein
viel einfacheres Beispiel. Du installierst einen Kubernetes-Cluster, hast eine Anwendung drin
deployed und willst jetzt, dass die Anwendung erreichbar ist aus dem Netzwerk. Good luck,
have fun bei einem lokalen Cluster. So, da hast du zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder du haust einen
Ingress drauf und setzt dich damit erst einmal drei, vier Tage auseinander, wie du das ordentlich
konfigurierst und was ist da für von den hunderttausend Optionen. Du musst erst mal den
passenden Ingress-Controller raussuchen, Ingress für dich. Meistens läuft es auf den offiziellen
Nginx raus. Dann die hunderttausend Optionen angucken, wie du das konfigurieren willst und
dich dann noch um Cert-Manager und Let's-Encrypt-Zertifikate kümmern und dann ist gut,
dann kannst du das so machen. Oder du kommst auf die glorreiche Idee, das zu machen, was die
offizielle Kubernetes-Doku sagt. Die sagt nämlich, dass es verschiedene Service-Typen gibt. Du kannst
dir einfach deine Anwendung in Kubernetes deployen und hängst ein Service davor. Ein Service ist
quasi sowas wie ein Loadbalancer in Kubernetes. Du deployst deine Anwendung und dann hängst du
so ein Service davor. So, und dann sagst du, ach, weißt du was, ich hätte gerne, dass meine Anwendung
aus dem Netzwerk erreichbar ist. Ordentlich. So, und dann kommst du früher oder später drauf,
du musst eigentlich Service-Typ-Loadbalancer benutzen. Und dann wirst du feststellen,
fuck, Service-Typ-Loadbalancer funktioniert bei meinem selbst installierten Kubernetes-Cluster-Lokal
gar nicht. Und dann stehst du erstmal da und denkst dir, ha, was mach ich denn jetzt? Warum geht
denn das nicht? Und dann wirst du irgendwann feststellen, ach so, damit Service-Typ-Loadbalancer
funktioniert, muss der jeweilige Anbieter, der den Kubernetes-Cluster hostet, das unterstützen.
Damit du das lokal selber machen kannst, wenn du nicht bei einem Cloud-Anbieter läufst,
musst du sowas wie beispielsweise MetalLB installieren. MetalLB macht quasi so eine
DHCP-Reservierung für deine, nennen wir es mal DHCP-Reservierung, für deine Loadbalancer-Ranges
und sowas. Wie gesagt, das ist eine echt komplizierte Angelegenheit und du schießt
dir mit Delay in den Fuß. Also meine Empfehlung an euch ist, sucht euch einen Cloud-Anbieter
und lasst das da laufen. Das ist wahrscheinlich für euch auf Dauer stressfreier und, auch wenn
es unterm Strich sicherlich teurer ist, als man erstmal vielleicht denkt, so nach dem Motto,
wenn man reingeht, ach ja, mit der Cloud sparen wir Geld, spart meistens kein Geld mit. Aber in
dem Fall, unterm Strich, spart ihr höchstwahrscheinlich damit Geld, weil ihr weniger
Ausfälle habt, weniger kaputt geht und weil ihr euch um die Sachen nicht kümmern müsst. Sucht
euch einen ordentlichen Cloud-Anbieter raus, also das von dem U-Boot gehört. Du meinst,
was bei dem Titanic-Frack rumgetaucht ist und die Leute verschollen sind? Ich habe nur gehört,
dass die irgendwie angeblich geklopft haben unter Wasser gestern. Haben die die jetzt gerettet oder
so? Habe ich nichts von mitgekriegt. Oder war das ein Prank? In der heutigen Zeit würde mich echt
nicht wundern. Vielleicht war das auch ein Prank. Bald kommt das Video. Ich meine, es gab letztens
den Prank, wie einer sein Flugzeug gecrashed hat. Vielleicht war das ja auch einer. Nee,
glaube ich nicht. So, also das ist das, was ich euch raten würde und es muss nicht Azure sein und es
muss auch nicht Google oder AWS sein. Ihr könnt auch mal einen Blick auf beispielsweise Digital
Ocean oder irgendwelche anderen Service-Anbieter werfen, ob die nicht für euch den Kubernetes
Cluster hosten können, weil Digital Ocean ist deutlich billiger als beispielsweise GKE. Dafür
hast du halt das ganze Google-Ökosystem nicht drumherum, falls du noch eine Managed Datenbank
oder sowas brauchst. Wobei, hat Digital Ocean auch. Ja, falls du noch ein Public PubSub oder
sowas brauchst. Ja, du hast nicht die gesamte Geschichte. Also ohne Mist, ich kann euch nur
wärmstens empfehlen, ich weiß nicht, was du noch geschrieben hast gleich. Ich kann euch wirklich nur
wärmstens empfehlen, sucht euch einen Anbieter und betreibt den Cluster dort. Eventuell ist sogar
ein Autopilot-Cluster bei Google das Richtige für euch, weil da müsst ihr euch um noch weniger
kümmern. In manchen Fällen ist es sogar billiger. So, was sagst du dazu, Deepox? Wie sieht deiner
Meinung nach die Zukunft von Windows-Servern aus? Ich glaube mehr oder weniger genauso wie jetzt.
Alles, was auf Linux lauffähig ist, ist mittlerweile schon auf Linux. Das Internet läuft auf Linux im
Endeffekt. Und das, was aktuell noch auf Windows läuft, wird wahrscheinlich auf absehbarer Zeit
auch auf Windows laufen. Das ist irgendwelches Active Directory, Microsoft-Zeug, keine Ahnung,
Office, Sharepoint, hast du nicht gesehen? Microsoft-Shit halt, ja? Und das wird in Zukunft
auch weiter. Also das hat sicherlich eine Zukunft, Windows-Server. Aber ich persönlich würde mich
nicht großartig darauf spezialisieren, weil mich Windows komplett abfuckt. Gerade Windows-Server.
Windows-Server ist echt der allergrößte Shit. Ich habe das hier im Stream schon mal ausprobiert.
Ich bin ja schon durchgedreht, nur einen DHCP-Server anzulegen. Weißt du, wir haben es doch... Haben wir
nicht tatsächlich mal sogar Linux-Fanboy für Windows-Admin? Ich bin durchgedreht, Leute. Hier,
guckt euch den Mist doch mal an. Wer will denn so einen Server administrieren? Ernsthaft? Mit
so einem hässlichen Dashboard und irgendeinem Wizard? Du kannst dich noch nicht mal ordentlich
Remote per Shell einloggen auf dem Ding, standardmäßig. Das Azure-AD-Zeug auf Linux,
das glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Unterschied zwischen Administrator und Dev? Ich weiß gar
nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll. Der Unterschied ist so offensichtlich, dass ich gar nicht weiß,
ob ich da noch was Neues zu beitragen kann. Hier entwickelst du Anwendungen, hier administrierst du
Server, auf denen Anwendungen laufen. Eventuell mit den ein oder anderen Überschneidungen.
Allerdings würde ich prinzipiell die Frage gar nicht mehr so extrem stellen im Jahr 2023,
weil ich der Meinung bin, dass die Zukunft, und die sieht man ja auch schon, im Entwicklungsbereich
geht immer mehr Richtung Full-Stack, so nach dem Motto, sollst einfach alles können und gleich noch
Zeit noch administrieren und DevOps die Kisten am besten auch gleich noch in der Cloud professionieren
und alles mögliche. Es gibt immer größere Überschneidungen. Natürlich wirst du nach wie
vor, und das wird es wahrscheinlich auch immer geben, Leute haben, die ihren gewissen Schwerpunkt
haben. Ja, wenn du jetzt den super krassen Java-Backend-Experten hast, der wird nicht auf
einmal anfangen, Linux-4Ms zu professionieren oder sowas. Aber trotzdem, ein bisschen vom anderen
Wissen ist immer nicht verkehrt und ich bin der Meinung, die Überschneidungen sind die letzten
Jahre nur immer größer geworden. Guckt euch meinen Stream an, ich bin noch das beste Beispiel für.
Oder guckt mich an. Ich habe angefangen bei einem Internet-Provider, habe ich meine Ausbildung
gemacht als Fachinformatiker Systemintegration, habe quasi Linux-Administration gelernt
damals und noch so ein paar Sachen drumherum, was man halt für im Rechenzentrum so braucht,
so was weiß ich, wie man Sachen patcht, wie man Server einbaut, wie man dort Teile tauscht und
Zeug halt in der Richtung, wie man bei IBM Ersatzteile bestellt, ohne die Fru-Nummer
und solche Geschichten, wie man Basic-Switches konfiguriert und so. Also ich habe da schon
ein paar Sachen mehr gelernt, aber hauptsächlich Linux. Und ich habe mich aber schon immer,
und das ist sicherlich so eine Sache, die ist jetzt bei mir halt so gewesen, ist nicht bei
jedem so, ich habe mich auch schon immer fürs Programmieren an sich interessiert und das ging
dann immer mehr in Richtung, okay, eigentlich hauptsächlich Linux, aber angefangen mit kleinen
Tools für interne Problemlösungen programmiert, auch mal das eine oder andere Webinterface für
was gebaut, dann angefangen mich mit Software-Versionierung, Versionsverwaltung zu
beschäftigen, als Git noch ganz neu war, wo die meisten noch SVN und solche Geschichten benutzt
haben, dann angefangen mit Server-Automatisierung, erst Puppet, dann später Ansible und irgendwann
ging es dann auch noch weiter, dass es immer mehr Cloud-Anwendungen gab, das Ganze muss dann mit
Terraform professioniert werden und so weiter, ja. Also das wächst immer weiter zusammen. Moin
Michael50Billionen. So. Bist du kalt, Chico, da oben grad, oder? Ich mach mal ein bisschen wärmer,
ne? Ja. Klimaanlage ist zu kalt eingestellt, wenn du da oben liegst. Was ist? Was ist, Chico?
Was ist? Wenn ich jetzt ne Webcam hätte, würde ich sagen, Chico, sag mal hallo, aber Chico hat
keinen Bock mehr. Ja. Ich? Nee. Wie kommst du da drauf? Bleib mir fern mit ActiveDirecting,
mache eine Umschulung momentan, deshalb bin ich nicht immer unter der Sonne, nur... Ja, gut,
dann mach das, was ich gesagt habe, mach dir Gedanken, was dir gefällt und guck, dass du
dich breit auskennst, aber in manchen Themen eben so dein, wie soll man sagen, Vorzeigedisziplin
ist. Halt in nem Thema, was dir gefällt. Weiß ich nicht, habe ich mich mit heute noch nicht
großartig beschäftigt. Ich gehe aber davon aus, dass die erste Version der Apple-Brille eher sich
an Entwickler richtet und nicht, dass man sich daheim damit dann irgendwas anguckt. Ich wollte
meine... Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist, kann ich dir nix dazu sagen. Wahrscheinlich PHP oder
sowas in der Richtung. Also, wenn du Web-Services auf Windows betreiben willst, kann ich dir sagen,
lass es bleiben, probier's unter Linux. Wo läuft bei dir Linux drauf? Auf ganz vielen Kisten. Ach,
du meinst jetzt hier, was ich im Stream immer zeige, gell? Das hier ist ne VM. Das hier,
das ist ne VM. Das hier, was ihr jetzt hier seht. White-Pepo-Happy-Sonnenuntergang. Das
ist ne VM. Guck. VM. Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass ich die auf zwei Desktops laufen habe.
Windows hier und Linux da. Also Linux hier, oh. Linux hier, Windows da und auf dem dritten Desktop
auch wieder Windows. Einholzvoll ist ein schöner Fehler. Ja, es gibt viele Fehler, wo man nicht
draufkommt. Wenn einer mit ch andere Dateien geändert hat, kommt da auch niemand drauf.
Lotus-Domino. Wer macht denn sowas freiwillig im Jahr 2023? Warum müssen wir reden? Ja,
reden ist quasi seit Anbeginn der Menschheit so eines der wichtigsten Sachen, die wir machen.
Können wir uns das? Ja, wenn das das ist, was ich denke. Ne, das ist nicht das, was ich denke. Doch,
das ist das, was ich denke. Was ich dachte. Aber ich fürchte, da werde ich nicht sonderlich
gut abschneiden. Bei Hackerman-Content. Ja, das gibt's. Es gibt ja einige Prometheus-Ergänzungen
mittlerweile. Oh, ich bin ziemlich weit hinten dran. Ja, also ich habe einen Luftfeuchtigkeitssensor,
einen Huminity-Sensor habe ich. Ich habe, ich habe, was habe ich denn am Start? Ich habe bestimmt
vier, fünf verschiedene. Also ich habe, ich habe fertige, ja. Achso, ne, ich empfehle dir einen.
Ich empfehle dir einen wirklich guten, wenn du ein bisschen basteln willst. Also gut in Form von
hält lange und lässt sich wunderbar in Home Assistant integrieren und hat richtig coole
Zusatzfunktionen. Und zwar, ähm, das da. Wenn ich so wüsste, wie die Dinger heißen. Ja,
kriegst du auch nicht, nicht das, die viereckige Variante meine ich, ja. Viel zu teuer. Musst bei
Aliexpress kaufen. Bei Aliexpress gibt es die teilweise für einen Apfel und ein Ei. Gucken wir
mal. Ah, okay, einen Euro wird es nicht wirklich kosten am Ende. Ja, sowas, sowas hier. Fünf Stück.
Was haben wir denn hier? Fünf Stück, 28 durch 5. Äh, nein. Guck mal, das ist ja billig. 5,60 Euro.
Ja, du musst mal bei einem anderen Shop gucken. Ja, du kannst Versand, Versand kann man eigentlich
immer umstellen. Ne, wieso? Geht doch. 1,49 ist doch gut. Ja, die sind gut. Und jetzt erzähle
ich dir auch warum. Und zwar, die kannst du flashen. Dazu brauchst du, aber nur wenn du die
flasht, sind die gut. Nur wenn du die flasht. Wenn du die flasht, kannst du die mit der Custom
Firmware flashen. Da gibt es einige, einige Custom Firmwares dafür. Das ist eins davon und
ähm, das, das, das ist, das ist beispielsweise hier so der, der aktuelle Fork. So, die kannst
du flashen. Und wenn du die geflasht hast, kannst du, kannst du folgende Sachen einstellen. Also,
zumindest eine Sache, eine Sache, die können kein ZigBee, die sind Bluetooth, die sind BLE,
Low Energy Bluetooth. Also, das Wichtigste, was du dann einstellen kannst, ist die, der Update
Intervall. Dann stellst du den Update Intervall erstmal auf eine Viertelstunde. Und auch den
Messintervall runter auf eine Viertelstunde. Und dann halten die Dinger bis zu drei Jahre. Ich
hab drüben im Bad eins, eins hängen. Das hat jetzt zweieinhalb Jahre auf dem Buckel. Kann man
damit die Außentemperatur einstellen? Achso, das war ein Witz. Ich hab's nicht verstanden.
Keck Weight. Aber die Dinger sind gut. Aber nur wenn du sie flasht und dann kannst du den
Home Assistant integrieren. Und dann ist es wahrscheinlich so ziemlich der günstigste und
beste Thermostat oder Thermometer, was du dir so holen kannst. Also, Thermometer und Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Wir haben gerade über das Flashen von einem Bluetooth-Thermometer geredet. Nein, haben wir
nicht. Achso, aber wo wir gerade dabei sind, im Stream machen. Wir haben das selbstverständlich
auch schon. Wir haben das selbstverständlich auch schon im Stream geflasht. China-Geräte flashen,
ist es da dabei gewesen? Nope, sieht nicht so aus. Mehr China-Geräte flashen, okay. Flash-Champ. Okay,
da wurde nix geflasht. Ja, ich find's nicht. Wir haben das auch schon im Stream geflasht. Oder war
das der Stream, den ich gelöscht hab, weil ich Dungeons bekommen hab während dem Stream? Wer sich
noch erinnert? Ich will nicht. Ich will nicht dran erinnert werden. Ich bin aber gerade irgendwie so,
gerade hat es mich dran erinnert. Nee, okay, ich glaube es geht. Doch, da liegt doch so ein Ding
hier oben. Das ist doch so ein Teil. Ja, vielleicht haben wir das auch hier geflasht. Nun gut. Das ist
ein gutes Thermometer und Luftfeuchtigkeit-Sensor. Jetzutz. Ohne Rancher nur deren Betrieb. Wie
gesagt, ich würde kein Kubernetes-Cluster selbst betreiben. Ganz, ganz ehrlich, ernst gemeinte
Advice. Was machen die? Keine Ahnung. Verfolge ich nicht. Ach, Chetke, lustig machen darüber,
wenn irgendwelche Leute ersoffen sind, will ich nicht unbedingt jetzt. Auch wenn ich jetzt den
Spielverderber spielen muss, ja. Nee, glaube ich nicht. Ich gehe davon aus, dass Azure Active
Directory auch Windows im Backend ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie da irgendwas auf Windows laufen
haben. Echt, bei was? Je nachdem, was, kann schon sein. Hypergadji. Ich weiß nicht,
worauf sich das bezogen hat. Ich bin zu weit hinten dran im Chat. SSH auf eine Windows-Server
installieren ist auch shit. Ja, richtiger Müll. Mittlerweile ist glücklicherweise SSH
standardmäßig mit dabei als Client. Wie bildet man sich am besten vom Admin zum DevOps weiter?
Ich glaube, da habe ich ja eben schon was zugesagt. Oder habe ich? Ja, ich habe mich
ja prinzipiell über den Werdegang bei mir ausgelassen. Ich glaube, das reicht als Antwort
für. Wir möchten es zwingend selbst betreiben. Wieso möchte ich nicht weiter auswirken? Alle
Themen, die du gerade angesprochen hast, habe ich entweder angekratzt oder mich tiefer damit
beschäftigt. Besonders Themen zu Disaster Recovery, mehrmals den Cluster kaputt gemacht
und zauberwiderstand. Heute noch die ersten Kundenapplikationen. Also, wenn ihr das machen
wollt. Ich kann euch da nicht aufhalten. Dann macht das halt. Freue mich an 50 Billionen.
Habe knapp 2K für ein Windows-Server Admin Zertifikat ausgegeben. Nach deinen Aussagen
scheint das komplett useless gewesen. Also, so war das nicht gemeint. Das habe ich auch
nicht gesagt. Also, wenn du dich im Windows-Bereich auskennst und im Windows-Bereich arbeiten willst
und du irgendwie Leute findest, die auf Zertifikate stehen. Warum nicht? Ist doch nicht verkehrt.
Ich persönlich finde Windows kacke. Ich würde freiwillig nichts mit Windows machen und ich
würde auch nicht freiwillig Windows administrieren oder zu Windows Admin werden. Wenn das ein Bereich
ist, der dir gefällt, wovon ich mal ausgehe, dass dir das gefällt. Sonst hättest du ja
wahrscheinlich kein Zertifikat gemacht. Sprich nichts dagegen. Nicht damit weiter auseinanderzusetzen.
Du musst jetzt nicht, nur weil ich Windows kacke finde, auf Linux umsatteln. Auf Linux
kann man eh nur setzen, wenn man Arch-Linux verwendet auf dem Desktop. By the way. Benutzt
du Arch-Linux? Ansonsten gehörst du eh nicht zum Club der Erleuchteten quasi. By the way.
Also, du kannst bei Windows bleiben. Du musst nicht, weil ich über Windows flame jetzt was
anderes machen. Aber um auf die eigentliche Frage einzugehen. Hast du Tipps, wie ich erste
Erfahrungen in Linux sammeln kann? Ja. Ich habe ein Video zugemacht auf YouTube. Da hieß
irgendwie was mit, warum Linux kein Ersatz für Windows ist oder sowas. Da geht es dann
aber im letzten Drittel tatsächlich darum, wie man sich da ein bisschen rantasten kann.
Aber da ging es hauptsächlich um Desktop-Anwender. Also, was ich dir empfehlen kann, ist, wenn
du dich mit Linux auseinandersetzen willst, probiere mal ein paar kleinere Projekte auf
dem Raspberry Pi. Falls du noch einen Raspberry Pi hast. Neu kaufen würde ich den nicht.
Bei den Preisen ist ja nur noch 140€ übrig. Aber dafür kannst du dir schon eine Low-Power
Intel x86-Kiste kaufen, die 4x schneller ist. Okay. 2-3x schneller ist. Ansonsten,
Vm geht ja genauso. Vom Raspberry Pi ist halt noch ein bisschen der Bastelfaktor verbunden.
Vm, Linux installieren. Nimm dir am besten ein Debian. Tatsächlich würde ich als Server-Betriebssystem
immer noch heutzutage empfehlen, damit anzufangen. Macht keinen Sinn. Irgendwie gleich mit Ubuntu,
weil Ubuntu macht 2-3 Sachen sehr eklig. Auch wenn es im Enterprise-Umfeld verbreiteter ist,
aber wer sich mit Debian auskennt, kommt auch ohne Probleme mit Ubuntu zurecht. Wer sich mit
Ubuntu auskennt, kommt nicht zwangsläufig immer mit Debian zurecht. Und im Red Hat Umfeld würde
ich mich, auch wenn es Enterprise wahrscheinlich das verbreitete System ist, erstmal zum Einstieg
gar nicht auseinandersetzen. Weil, ganz ehrlich, RPM ist einfach Ultra-Pains-Champ,
wenn man das mit Debian, oder generell ist Red Hat Ultra-Pains-Champ, wenn man Debian gewöhnt ist.
Und das sage ich als jemand, der wahrscheinlich schon seit über, lass mal überlegen, 2000,
der seit 16 Jahren fast sein Geld verdient im Enterprise-Leanungsumfeld und damit hauptsächlich
Red Hat. Aber ich mag Red Hat nicht. Und auch CentOS und die anderen Abkömmlinge von Red Hat
nicht. Also wenn du kein Raspberry Pi hast, installiere dir ein Debian in der VM und bastel
ein bisschen mit rum. Aber am besten ist tatsächlich, du installierst ein Leanungssystem,
sowas wie Arch beispielsweise, wenn du dich tatsächlich im Detail ein bisschen mit
auseinandersetzen willst, setzt das selbst auf in der VM und machst einfach tägliche Tasks damit.
Du musst da nicht drauf spielen, du musst auch nicht deine Windows-Sachen da drauf zum Laufen
bringen, das meine ich nicht. Aber mach tägliche Administrator-Tasks damit. Dich remote irgendwo
einloggen, was nachgucken, einfach nur Webseiten damit aufmachen und ein bisschen surfen und
gucken und ausprobieren. Durch tägliche Benutzen mit einem Linux-Desktop lernt man auch sehr viel
drumherum. Wenn du Sachen skriptest, entwickelst, mach das unter Linux. Adi schreibt, bin froh,
dass ich meinen Einstiegstest für die Ausbildung vorhin geschafft habe. Das erste Mal mit HTML
und JavaScript gearbeitet. Du hast einen Einstiegstest, wo die dich Sachen zu HTML und
JavaScript gefragt haben und du hast den Einstiegstest geschafft, obwohl du vorher nie
was mit HTML und JavaScript gemacht hast. Das ist nicht schlecht. Hast du mal ein Beispiel,
was die da so gefragt haben? Schreib mal Ed Wubblers mit in die Antwort, falls du antwortest,
das interessiert mich tatsächlich. Was haben die da so gefragt? Nix. Ich würde Debian installieren.
Hast du schon ein Fazit zu deinem neuen Job? Na ja Fazit? Fazit kann ich ein paar Jahre vielleicht
geben. Nach zweieinhalb Monaten noch nicht. Ich habe jetzt vielleicht den ersten Eindruck,
habe ich euch schon öfters im Stream erzählt. Es ist halt super restriktiv. Wir haben auf den
Windows Kisten 20 Sachen im Hintergrund laufen, die Viren scannen und Malware versuchen zu
blocken. Ich habe letztens mal wieder vorgeschlagen, Jungs, wie wäre es denn mit Linux Clients für alle?
Das finden die da irgendwie überhaupt nicht bedenkenswert, was ich komisch finde, weil damit
hätte man viele Probleme nicht, die man mit Windows Clients versucht mit tausendfacher Zusatzsoftware
zu lösen. Das stimmt, das kann ich auch sagen. Ja, nach meiner Erfahrung gibt es unglaublich wenig
gute Windows Admins. Die meisten Windows Admins, wisst ihr, wie meine Erfahrung mit den meisten
Windows Admins aussieht? Das schaut ungefähr so aus. Ich gehe da hin, also gehen wir mal noch von
Zeiten aus, wo man vor Ort zu den Leuten gegangen ist. Ich gehe da hin und sage, nehmen wir mal was
simples. Keine Ahnung, von Account XY ist das Passwort ausgelaufen oder sowas. Das müssen wir mal
resetten. So, da gehe ich hin und in dem Adminbüro von Windows Leuten ist eh schon immer ganz cringige
Atmosphäre. Zumindest habe ich das immer von Windows Admin Büros so erlebt. Da gehst du rein
und sagst, ja, hier musst du mal das Passwort resetten. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen, ist ja auch
egal, warum du hingehst da. Irgendwie hat kein Zugriff mehr. Könnt ihr mal kurz im AD gucken,
der Username, das resetten. Und da kommt dann entweder sowas wie, ach, heute schon der zehnte,
dem das so geht. Ich weiß auch nicht, was die Leute immer machen. Da ist immer so übelst cringe
Atmosphäre in Windows Admin Büros. So, und dann gehst du dann da rein und stellst dich halt neben
denen und irgendeiner. Du guckst dann die Leute an und keiner hat Bock, irgendwas zu machen. Dann
stellst du dich halt mal zu einem und er sagt, ja, okay, ich gucke halt nach und dann sieht das so
aus. Passt mal auf, wenn du dem 0815 Windows Admin zuguckst, dann sieht das ungefähr so aus. User,
User Passwort resetten. Ich klicke jetzt einfach mal irgendwas an. Hier muss er hin, hier muss er
hin. Ja, und du stehst hinter dem und denkst die ganze Zeit. Alter, klick da drauf, klick hier drauf,
klick dahin und du guckst ihm dann zu Netzwerk Change Homepage und irgendwann und irgendwann
nach zehn Minuten oder so hat der Typ dann das Passwort reset. Das sind so meine Erfahrungen
mit Windows Admin. Nee, ich übertreibe nicht. Genauso sind meine Erfahrungen mit Windows Admin.
Nein, habe ich nicht. Wollte ich eigentlich heute, aber irgendwie wieder verdrängt. Ach stimmt,
das kam ja vor zwei Tagen raus. Wisst ihr, mittlerweile ist es halt echt im Internet so
ein Ding. Also ich habe mitbekommen, dass neues Final Fantasy rausgekommen ist. Ich
hatte es wieder vergessen und heute auf der Startseite auf YouTube Final Fantasy 16 Buba
Szene. Ich wusste mit Achtung Krach, dass neues Final Fantasy rausgekommen ist, aber so ist das
halt. Kriegst du gleich die wichtigen Sachen empfohlen auf YouTube. Was sind für dich aktuell
die besten Alternativen für einen Raspberry Pi? OCR von PDF. Keine Ahnung, ich wüsste nicht mal,
wie ich das gescheit mit dem Raspberry Pi mache. Also die besten Alternativen zu einem Raspberry
Pi sind aktuell. Irgendwelche low power billige x86 Hardware, sowas mit mit aufgelöteter CPU,
sowas für für 60 Euro oder 70 60 70 Euro. Da kriegst du brauchst halt noch RAM. Ja,
aber du kommst ungefähr für den Preis damit raus, wie ein Raspberry Pi kostet. Hast aber
noch eine kleine SSD dabei und mehr RAM und mehr CPU Power. Ansonsten, ich finde, es gibt keine
Alternative zum Raspberry Pi. Es gibt einige x86 Low Power x86 Kisten, die preis-leistungsmäßig okay
sind, auch ordentlich Power haben. Es gibt ein paar Single Board Computer, die sagen wir mal vom
Formfaktor Konkurrenz machen zum Raspberry Pi oder auch von dem Stromverbrauch Konkurrenz machen zum
Raspberry Pi, von der Leistungsfähigkeit Konkurrenz machen, Erweiterbarkeit, was auch immer. Aber es
gibt kein Komplettpaket wie den Raspberry Pi. Das gibt's einfach nicht. Der Raspberry Pi ist mehr
als so ein Board. Das ist das gesamte Ökosystem. 150 Jahre Tutorials zum Raspberry Pi, ein super
angepasstes Betriebssystem mit allem, was du brauchst. Tausende Header, Erweiterungen,
Fertiggitter Repos, Scripts, Projekte, alles. Es gibt keine Alternative zum Raspberry Pi. Zum
Mindest keine, die ebenbürtig ist. Du kannst dir ein paar Punkte raussuchen, die dir wichtig sind an
deinem Projekt. Dann findest du eine Alternative. Aber wenn du wirklich eine Alternative suchst,
die ebenbürtig ist zum Raspberry Pi, in diesen ganzen Belangen, die gibt es einfach nicht. Ja,
habe ich. Weiß gar nicht. Ne, habe ich nicht installiert. Leute, ich habe PowerPoint installiert.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen? Ich habe ein Office 365 Abo. Schrecklich. Das hatten wir schon. Ich
glaube, ich habe nichts übersehen. Wie hast du die mit BLE-HR Connected, mit einem Pluto-Stick oder
ESP? Äh, mit einem ESP. Schon bevor es diese neuen BLE-Proxys gab. Wir haben ja auch im Stream
gemacht, by the way. Wir haben ja im Stream schon alles Wirkliche gemacht. Wir haben...
Der fehlt? Oder habe ich den... Ja gut, ich weiß halt immer nicht, wie die Titel hießen. Hier.
Clips. Da gibt es noch Clips. Der eigentliche Stream ist verloren gegangen, so wie es aussieht.
Ich glaube, den Stream gibt es nicht mehr. Da haben wir eine eigene Firmware für den ESP32
programmiert, zum Abgreifen von BLE-Signalen von Xiaomi-Geräten und dann weiterleiten über
MQTT und Home Assistant. Mittlerweile... Also ich habe das damals gemacht, weil ich wollte die
Thermostate, eine Waage und einen Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor in Home Assistant bringen und ich
wollte die Geräte nicht pollen, sondern Listen machen mit dem Plutus... Im Plutus-Netz quasi
lauschen, ob was reinkommt und dann weiterleiten an Home Assistant. Also das haben wir damals
selbst programmiert. Mittlerweile ist es easy, weil es für Home Assistant schon fertige Firmware
gibt, das in ESP als Plutus-Proxy agiert. Der nimmt dann die Sachen entgegen und schickt es
per WLAN an Home Assistant. Das ist mittlerweile total einfach. Ja, die DHT22-Dinger sind ziemlich
ungenau, aber besser als nix. Besser ist als Sensor, wenn man wirklich sowas selbst bauen
will, ist als Sensor die Dinger von Bosch. Ich habe gerade vergessen, wie die heißen. Aber
ansonsten, wenn es billig sein muss, sind die Dinger ganz gut. Nee, war es nicht. Die sehen
sich aber relativ ähnlich. Es war keine Mehrrostleiste, das war eine... Kogig heißen die,
glaube ich. Einen China-Hersteller, der ESP32 verbaut hat. Nee, ESP2866 verbaut hat, die sich
noch OTA haben flashen lassen. Rust? Ich habe noch keinen Rust-Stream. Achso, doch! Ich habe
mal in Rust was probiert, aber das... Da haben wir nicht wirklich viel Rust gemacht in dem Stream.
DaniLul, dankeschön für den Sub. Ich muss gerade mal gucken. Nicht, dass ich wieder was hier
übersehen habe. An Subscribers? Fuck, das Dashboard sieht jetzt anders aus. Man erkennt nix mehr. Das
Wichtigste haben sie verkackt wieder. Ich sehe nicht, wer subscribed hat. Follows? Was interessieren
mich Follows? Ich will jetzt Follows und Subscriber. Alter Twitch, das ist doch jetzt nicht euer Ernst,
oder? Okay, na, hier gibt es noch was. Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt. Aber da sehe ich auch nicht,
wer. Das gab es sonst immer eine super Übersicht, wer alles subscribed hat. Das ist jetzt einfach
weg. Das ist ja schlimm. Stream-Manager vielleicht? Okay, Stream-Manager, da ist es. Die haben einfach
die Startseite umgeändert. Ich habe nichts übersehen. Doch, Mr. Moogame, den habe ich
übersehen, aber es war schon vor einer Weile. Nee, das ist ja auch kompaniertes Selbstbetrieben. Das
würde ich gerade nicht machen, wenn man da keine Ahnung von hat. Bist du zufrieden mit deinem
aktuellen Rechner? Ja. Keinerlei Stabilitätsprobleme und Leistung mehr als irgendwelche
NASA-PCs. Also insofern, ja. Kommt drauf an, wie viele Nodes du hast. Aber gerade ZEV dann auch noch
zusätzlich Selbstbetreiben. Also ich würde mir das echt an eurer Stelle noch mal überlegen. Aber gut,
man. Mehr als sagen, wie ich es machen würde, kann ich ja nicht. Also wenn ihr das nicht wollt,
dann Arches to Mainstream. Also muss man jetzt Gentoo machen und quasi, wenn man einen Anhang
bekommt in irgendeinem Open-Office-Format, erstmal 45 Minuten kompilieren. Erstmal LibreOffice
kompilieren. Red Hat vernagelt Zugang zu öffentlich. Alter, Red Hat. Ist auch so ein richtiger Kackladen,
Alter. Die Sacken. Also heute Vorstellungsgespräch gehabt. Der Andi. Nee, der Adi. Als Visi sollte
einen Web-Server vm installieren und vor... Moment. Ich kann nicht lesen. Sekunde. Als Visi sollte
eine Web-Server vm installieren und Vor-Name, Nachnamen plus Anrede-Eingabe-Button drücken
und dann Begrüßung mit... Warte mal. Du solltest eine Seite erstellen mit einem Input und wenn du
dann ein Button drückst, soll dann irgendwie ein Alert kommen mit Hallo Max Mustermann oder so,
wenn man das vorher eingegeben hat. Ja gut, das ist tatsächlich easy. Finde ich eigentlich ganz
gut, dass man bei einem Visi beides abfragt, weil wisst ihr warum? Ich gehe davon aus,
dass der Einstellungstest für Anwendungsentwickler und Visi wahrscheinlich exakt der gleiche ist bei
denen. Und es ist gar nicht mal verkehrt, beides zu checken. Deswegen gibt es ja auch so wenig gute
Windows-Admins. Chico, willst du wieder raus? Ja, ich lass dich raus. Moment. So, musste mal kurz
der Katze die Tür aufmachen. Das ist gut. Die kann man ja leider nicht mehr flashen, weil die
keine ESPs mehr verbauen. Ich habe es geschafft, Leute. Chat durch. Ich habe bestimmt irgendwas
übersehen. Falls ihr irgendwas übersehen habt, schreibt es einfach nochmal hin. Ansonsten,
nice. Das hat jetzt eine Weile gedauert. Aber ich habe ja gesagt, wir müssen reden,
Chat. Und das machen wir. Ich bin jetzt auch zu faul für... Ich schmeiße einfach alles in den
Schrank und wenn ich irgendwann mal was brauche, suche ich zwei Stunden, bis ich es gefunden habe.
Also ich habe mir so ein Multifunktionsgerät gekauft letztens. Der hat auch einen Dokumenteneinzug,
aber das geht halt nicht, wenn die Dinger zusammengetackert sind. Aber Leute, das war
eines der besten Investitionen in den letzten paar Monaten, dass ich mir den neuen Drucker
gekauft habe. Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, wie dieses Ding hieß. So ein Multifunktionsgerät.
Wartet mal, ich gucke mal kurz. Der hatte so einen absolut unaussprechlichen Kacknamen. Und
zwar, ich habe gekauft einen... Hier ist er. Okay, ich habe gekauft einen Brother MFC L3750 CDW.
Also richtig, richtig harter Cringe, wer sich das nicht merken kann. Übrigens nicht zu verwechseln
mit dem MFC L3730 CDN. Der hat nämlich keinen WLAN. So, das Teil habe ich mir gekauft. Das
ist ein bisschen teurer, aber ich habe mir das aus einem Grund gekauft, weil ich überhaupt
keinen Bock mehr hatte auf Tintenstrahler, die nicht funktionieren, wenn ich mal was
drucken muss. So, das ist ein Farblazer-Drucker. Also das ist wirklich das Komplettpaket. Mehr
Drucker brauche ich die nächsten Jahre nicht mehr. Das ist echt das Komplettpaket. Das
ist ein Farblazer-Drucker mit Fax. Sehr wichtig, heutzutage noch. Fax, dementsprechend Dokumenteneinzug,
oder Flachblatt-Scanner, dementsprechend Kopierfunktion und halt Farblazer-Druck. Das Schöne ist,
der hat einen USB-Stick-Anschluss, da kann man auch... Oh, haben die neuen USB-C? Sehe
ich das richtig? Ne, nur noch einen USB. Die haben einen USB-Anschluss, da kannst du dann
auch per USB, kannst du direkt auf USB scannen, du kannst direkt auf ein Windows-Share scannen,
alles mögliche. Das ist echt Komplettpaket-Drucker für mich. Diesmal habe ich mir gedacht, weißt
du was, scheiß drauf, gib halt mal irgendwie 400, 450 Euro für das Ding aus, du brauchst
die nächsten Jahre dich nicht um irgendwas zu kümmern, der Drucker geht einfach, auch
wenn er ein halbes Jahr aus war, wenn du was drucken willst, dann druckt er einfach und
funktioniert. Und dementsprechend habe ich es mal in den sauren Apfel gewissen und einfach
immer ordentlich Kohle für ausgegeben. Ja, so sieht's aus. Ok, eben gab's hier eine etwas
längere Message im Chat. Snakebeard schreibt, sag mal, wie macht ihr das eigentlich als
Softwareentwickler, wenn ihr euch nach neuen Stellen umseht, weil ihr mal was Neues machen
wollt, sprich, wie holt ihr euch bewerbungsrelevante Erfahrungen in neuen Technologien? Bewerbungsrelevante
Erfahrungen in neuen Technologien, also im besten Fall hast du ja schon Erfahrungen in
dem, also von dem, was du machst, vielleicht sich das transferieren lässt, den neuen Job,
also ganz ehrlich, bewerbungsrelevante Erfahrungen in neuen Technologien, das klingt für mich
so, als suchst du was Bestimmtes, dann musst du dir das wohl selbst angucken. Also, ich
meine, dir wird auch so nichts anderes da übrig bleiben, als dir das selbst anzugucken,
wenn du denkst, dass das relevant ist dafür. Ich meine, was willst du machen, deine aktuelle
Arbeitgeber, machts nicht. Ja, mal angenommen, du machst aktuell nur .NET Backend, willst
dich aber ein bisschen, was JavaScript Frontend angeht, schlau machen, dann wirst du dich
damit selbst beschäftigen müssen. Oder vielleicht hast du bei deinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber auch
die Möglichkeit, das zu machen, aber du wirst nicht drumherkommen, dir selbst ein paar kleine
Projekte lokal anzugucken und zu basteln. Aber ich kann dir eine Sache sagen, hat sich
auch wieder bestätigt, ich hab doch letztens mit meinem Chef drüber geredet, der war der
gleichen Ansicht, viele Arbeitgeber in der IT, also generell wird in vielen Stellenanzeigen
geschrieben, aber du musst nicht alles davon erfüllen, aber viele Arbeitgeber in der IT,
denen geht es heute hauptsächlich darum, jemanden zu finden, der grundlegend Ahnung hat und gewillt
ist, sich einzuarbeiten. Das reicht schon. Und wenn du Erfahrung hast in der Programmiersprache
schon seit ein paar Jahren, dann kommst du wahrscheinlich relativ schnell auch in andere
Technologien rein. Also ich würde nicht so sehr davor zurückschrecken, bei einer Bewerbung,
auch auf Stellen, wo du nicht alles erfüllst. Ich meine, wenn die jetzt sagen, must have,
keine Ahnung, Kobol-Erfahrung, weil das für IBM Mainframe ist und du weißt weder, was das ist,
noch hast du jemals eine Zeile Kobol programmiert, ja dann ist das vielleicht keine allzu gute Idee.
Wenn die aber einen Kobol-Entwickler suchen und du wolltest schon immer mal Kobol machen und du
sagst, hey Leute, ich kann mich da auch einarbeiten, let's go. Aber ansonsten ist das in der IT
eigentlich doch immer das Gleiche. Egal, ob es irgendwelche neuen Technologien sind,
irgendwelche Cloud-Geschichten ausprobieren, irgendwelche Linux-Sachen, irgendwelche neuen
Services, was auch immer. Man muss sich privat, also man muss sich dafür interessieren und man
muss sich privat damit beschäftigen. Anderweitig geht es doch eigentlich gar nicht. Guck mal,
ich meine, ich habe mal Fachinformatiker Systemintegration gelernt und ich würde mal
fast sagen, dass bestimmt die Hälfte, wenn nicht sogar deutlich mehr, was wir an Themen im Stream
behandeln, keine klassischen Physi-Sachen sind. Also zumindest mal alle Progger-Streams,
wo Zeug programmiert wird von Backend bis Frontend, sind auf jeden Fall keine Physi-Themen. Ja,
der hat Wireless in Farbe und der kann so zweiseitig drucken, genau. Und ja, auch tatsächlich ein
wichtiger Hinweis, das stimmt schon, was er hier schreibt, ein GitHub-Link in der Bewerbung ist
nicht verkehrt. Ich hatte auch einen GitHub-Link in der Bewerbung und das, obwohl ich mich als
Linux-Engineer beworben habe bzw. eigentlich eher geworben wurde, aber trotzdem habe ich einen
GitHub-Link mitgeschickt. Ich glaube, das kommt immer gut an. Das ist übrigens auch der einzige
Grund, warum ich meine GitHub-Projekte ein bisschen geordnet habe für die Bewerbung,
ansonsten hat das keinen Sinn, ansonsten hätte ich nie meine Projekte geordnet,
sinnlos einfach stehen lassen. Also ich wollte, dass die beispielsweise die Projekte mit den
Sternen vorne sehen und die ordentlicheren Projekte auch vorne stehen sehen und nicht
unbedingt jetzt als erstes auf das Projekt treffen, wo ich 50 mal keckw reingeschrieben
habe. Es gibt zum Beispiel noch ein uralt Projekt, da habe ich einen Witz gemacht im
Stream und habe es dann committet und wenn das hier jemand sieht, der denkt dann auch,
ich bin nicht mehr ganz dicht, was auch immer hier gecastet wird. Was ist denn nur mit casten
los? Und danach habe ich aber nie wieder was weitergemacht an dem Tool, deswegen steht es
jetzt halt hier schon seit sechs Jahren drin. Tintenstrahldrucker-Beste. Ganz ehrlich,
der Tintenstrahldrucker, Laserdrucker-Beste. Ich hätte überhaupt keinen Bock mehr,
mich mit Tintenstrahldruckern rumzuschlagen. Was sagst du zu City Skylines 2? Ich sage dazu,
dass ich nicht mal City Skylines 1 richtig gespielt habe. Ich glaube beidseitiges Scannen
hat er nicht, obwohl ich mir da ehrlich gesagt gar nicht sicher bin. Ich glaube aber nicht.
Oder vielleicht doch? Weiß nicht. Naja, das ist vielleicht keine allzu gute Idee,
um neue Technologien kennenzulernen. Wilde Copy-Paste-Mischung aus Chat-GPT und Copilot.
Naja, im Vergleich zu einem Tintenstrahldrucker ist es schon ordentlich. Tintenstrahldrucker
kriegst du ab 80 Euro. Oh doch, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Ja, YouTube-Tutorials gehören auf
jeden Fall dazu. Es gibt richtig gute Channels, gerade im .NET-Umfeld, aber im JavaScript-Umfeld,
es gibt richtig gute Tutorials und Channels auf YouTube. Auch wenn man sich mit Kubernetes
und Cloud-Sachen beschäftigen will. Ja, es gibt richtig gute Channels. Ist auf jeden Fall
sinnvoll. Man muss nicht zwangsläufig alles mal von Hand gemacht haben, um so grob im Hinterkopf
zu behalten, was es so gibt. Frage an Leute, die arbeiten. Hatte Freitag das erste Mal ein
Gespräch für mehr Geld. Hab nach 10% mehr gefragt. Hab ich bekommen und noch Angebot
für Fortbildung. Mein Umfeld sagt mir aber, ich hab zu wenig verdient. Also ganz ehrlich,
wenn ich dir das einfach so easy geben, hättest du locker noch mehr verlangen können. Ja,
höchstwahrscheinlich. Ja, Nick Chaps, das macht gute Videos. Aber 10% ist doch erst einmal nicht
verkehrt. Natürlich kann man jetzt sagen, okay, wenn du dir mal anguckst, wie sich das entwickelt
hat die letzten Jahre, hast du halt trotzdem einfach mal immer noch weniger Geld, als noch
vor ein paar Jahren in der Hand. Aber 10% schon mal besser als nix. Und es hält dich ja auch keiner
davon ab, Ende des Jahres nochmal zu fragen. Oder wenn du es für richtig hältst. Also wenn du den
Zeitpunkt für günstig hältst, sollte ich vielleicht sagen. Also das ist was, was Arbeitgeber
immer gerne erzählen. So nach dem Motto, warum sollte, also prinzipiell fragen die dich dann so
Dinge. Warum sollte ich dir mehr Geld geben, wenn du doch genau das gleiche machst wie vorher? Ja,
die Sache ist bloß die, letztendlich, was passiert denn, wenn ihr arbeiten geht? Deswegen
finde ich das Argument immer so bescheuert, was da kommt. Das war ganz im Ernst. Was passiert,
wenn ihr arbeiten geht? Euer Arbeitgeber kann unterm Strich eure Arbeitskraft zu Geld machen.
Und eure Arbeitskraft ist schlicht und ergreifend in Zahlen mehr wert geworden, die letzten Jahre.
Also insofern, ihr müsst nicht mehr machen, um mehr zu verdienen. Es reicht schon, wenn ihr das gut
macht. Also die ganze Zeit macht, um mehr wert zu sein. Muss man vielleicht ein bisschen netter
verkaufen. Aber so auf diese Sache nach dem Motto, gibt nicht mehr, weil du nicht mehr machst,
finde ich, ist immer schlechte, ist immer Fail-Argumentation. Gerade in den heutigen Zeiten,
wo es halt einfach in Zahlen teurer geworden ist alles. Und selbstverständlich kann auch
dein Arbeitgeber mehr verlangen, rein in Zahlen. Und das muss sich irgendwie auch bei den Leuten
widerspiegeln. Aber mal davon abgesehen, eigentlich können sich Arbeitgeber im IT-Sektor eh nicht
großartig leisten, irgendwelche Tricks und Spielereien da zu machen. Wenn man denn prinzipiell
gewillt ist, mal sich ein bisschen umzugucken. Das heißt ja nicht zwangsläufig, dass man sich
gleich was Neues suchen muss. Ich bin auch nicht der Meinung, dass man alle paar Monate oder jedes
Jahr sich irgendwie einen neuen Job suchen sollte oder sowas. Wozu? Ja, gut, ich mein, es mag Leute
geben, da ist das die beste Entscheidung und sind nicht glücklich da, wo sie sind. Also prinzipiell
bin ich jetzt auch kein wirklicher Job-Hopper. Ich meine, es sind jetzt drei Jobs in 15 Jahren
oder so gewesen. Es ist nicht, dass ich laufend gewechselt bin oder so. Naja, aber in der heutigen
Zeit ist es einfach so, die suchen händeringend so extrem rar quasi die Leute geworden. Gerade
Leute, die auch wirklich Ahnung haben. Und das Beste ist tatsächlich, sich ein bisschen links
und rechts umzugucken, was es so gibt. Denn dadurch lernst du auch letztendlich, was du da
erfordern kannst. Und man muss sich mal überlegen, wenn man schon aktuell einen Job hat, ist das die
beste Situation, aus der man sich herausbewerben kann. Weil ihr könnt das total entspannt angehen.
Ihr müsst nicht nervös sein beim Vorstellungsgespräch, weil wenn es nicht klappt, ihr habt noch euren
normalen Job. Ihr könnt euch auch wirklich nur das raussuchen, was euch gut gefällt, weil ihr habt
es nicht nötig. Ihr habt ja noch euren normalen Job. Und da profitiert beides von. Ihr lernt so ein
bisschen, was ihr denn fordern könnt bei dem anderen. Also was denn so üblich ist. Was denn Leute für
euch bezahlen würden. Und vielleicht ist ja wirklich was Gutes bei. Und ihr habt danach einen besseren
Job mit Sachen, die euch wichtig sind, plus mehr Geld, plus mehr Homeoffice, plus Kinderbetreuung und
sonst was. Bieten ja viele Arbeitgeber mittlerweile an. Und ihr habt dann vielleicht einen besseren Job
unterm Strich. Vielleicht kommt ja noch was Gutes raus. Also sich einfach ein bisschen umschauen, ist
sicherlich nicht verkehrt. Und man kann auch beispielsweise super Vorstellungsgespräche. Scorpius,
danke für den Zap. Man kann auch super Vorstellungsgespräche üben. Weil viel entspannter wird man in einem
Vorstellungsgespräch nicht mal sein, als in der Situation. Ihr wisst, wenn ihr rausgeht, ist egal, ob es geklappt hat oder nicht.
Da kann man tatsächlich üben und auch mal drauf achten. Okay, wie mache ich denn das jetzt? Und wenn es dann mal
drauf ankommt, seid ihr besser, weil ihr schon geübt habt. Ein bisschen Übung schadet nicht. Also ich kann es nur
empfehlen, ein bisschen rumgucken, auch wenn man einen Job hat. Was du vermutest stimmt, passt schon sehr genau.
Im Moment mache ich hauptsächlich C-Sharp Backend. Würde aber gerne mal ein Wissen in Fächern, also C++...
Sicher? Bist du dir wirklich sicher, ja? Also C++ ist ja wirklich das Schlimmste, was man überhaupt machen kann.
Okay, würde aber gerne mal ein Wissen in Fächern, also C++ oder ASP.NET. By the way, du willst nicht
ASP.NET, du willst ASP.NET Core mit Blazor, weil Microsoft Benamungsscheiße ist. Es ist ASP.NET Core. Ja, aber...
Ja, gut. Ich glaube, das Beste ist tatsächlich, dich privat damit zu beschäftigen. Was anderes wird schwierig.
Die sind mittlerweile erfinderisch. Ich meine, die kriegen ja auch fette Prämien, wenn sie Leute vermitteln.
Bei uns gibt es 2000 Euro. Okay, stimmt nicht, aber ich sage euch den genauen Betrag nicht. Ich sage euch jetzt einfach nur mal irgendwas.
So, in dem Dreh. Bei uns gibt es 2000 Euro, wenn du jemanden vermittelst, der dann auch einen Vertrag kriegt.
Und das ist nix im Vergleich zu dem, was irgendwelche Personalvermittler kriegen. Die kriegen irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 5 Monatsgehälter oder sowas.
Oder je nachdem, wenn es so Zwischenverschacherfirmen sind, kriegen die sogar permanent vom gehaltenen Teil ab.
Also das ist richtig lukrativ, Leute zu vermitteln. Ja, habe ich mir da auch gedacht.
Das ist richtig, aber so ganz stimmt das nicht, aber ist schon okay für heute. Ja, der macht gute Videos.
Ja, aber viel haben wir nicht gemacht in Rust.
Da sind mir die Fragen, wo man steht. Werde ich einer T-Admin mit 40k Gehalt? Ja.
Also 40k mit ein bisschen Berufserfahrung ist auch unterirdisch heutzutage.
Ich kann immer nur mein Einstiegsgehalt als Vergleich nehmen. Und das ist vor 15 Jahren her.
Mein allererstes Gehalt nach der Ausbildung, als ich noch beim Internetprovider war und das war auch keine Firma, die irgendwie bekannt dafür war, es irgendwie übermäßig gut zu bezahlen.
Habe ich 33.500 Euro gekriegt und fand das eigentlich schon ganz nice.
So und wenn man das mal anpasst, wenn man da mal drauf rechnet, was ich dann 15 Jahren getan hat, dann ist 40k Gehalt zum Einstieg gerade so vielleicht noch okay.
Aber da sollte es auch schon eher in Richtung 45 gehen, denke ich.
Und mit ein bisschen Erfahrung darf es durchaus dann auch schon mal 60, 70k plus gehen.
Je nachdem, welche Branche, welche Region, was man genau macht.
Natürlich ist das immer ein bisschen schwierig, so pauschal zu sagen.
Denkst du, der Fachinformatiker stirbt aus, wenn er mehr... Nö, denke ich nicht.
Ja, Gehaltserhöhung hat nichts mit Weiterbildung zu tun.
Gebe ich dir recht, eine Weiterbildung von den Leuten sollte eigentlich im eigenen Interesse des Unternehmens liegen, für das man arbeitet.
Und außerdem ist es ja nicht so, als ist es ein Geschenk an dich, sondern du kannst ja danach, also je nachdem, wenn es eine kack Weiterbildung ist dann nicht, aber du lernst ja dort auch was, was dem Unternehmen wieder was bringt.
Also insofern ist das eigentlich nix, was in irgendeiner Art und Weise Bestandteil von Gehaltsverhandlungen sein sollte.
Sollte man eher fragen, warum ging das die letzten paar Jahre nicht? Warum gab's da nix?
Aktuell kann man gut Stonks machen.
Du programmierst in VBA so Excel-Sachen.
Woah!
Excel-V... Excel-VBA.
Aber gut, jeder was ihm Spaß macht.
Um mehrere Abteilungen...
Ja... Achso, ja.
Ja gut, dann war das keine Geschichte in Form von, du kannst eine Ausbildung machen anstatt mehr Geld, das hat er dir einfach so noch dabei erzählt.
Ja, dann ist ja wieder was anderes.
Und mal davon abgesehen, das ist eigentlich eher ein Grund dafür, dass sie dir mehr bezahlen sollten und den anderen auch.
Ich mein, guck mal, ich kann das nur aus Frankfurter Finanzbranche sagen.
Man kennt doch auch die Leute, also man kennt erstens mal die Leute, die in dem Unternehmen arbeiten, wo man selbst gerade ist.
Dort kennt man nicht nur welche aus dem eigenen Team, sondern wenn man eine Weile dabei ist auch alle anderen.
Und selbstverständlich, man redet ja da auch übers Geld.
So.
Ab und zu mal.
Also, davon so zu tun, als wüsste keiner was, ist ja schon mal bescheuert.
Und außerdem, kennt man ja auch Leute, die woanders arbeiten.
Ich mein, Frankfurt ist jetzt, ist kompakt, ja.
Also, wenn man jemanden kennt, mit dem man früher zusammengearbeitet hat, hat der wahrscheinlich nach ein paar Jahren drei Firmen durch.
Und man kann ihn fragen, wie sieht es eigentlich bei dir so aus, wenn man mit den Leuten noch Kontakt hat.
Also, man weiß auch meistens nicht nur, wie es im eigenen Unternehmen aussieht, sondern man weiß auch meistens so ein bisschen, wie so übliche Gehälter drumherum aussehen.
Was natürlich ein guter Vorteil ist.
Dass man so schon ungefähr weiß, okay, ist es jetzt wirklich so übertrieben, was man gesagt hat, oder wollen sie mir das nur einreden.
Ja gut, das ist ja auch der Grund, warum wir Fachkräftemangel haben.
So in der Essenz, ja.
Fachkräftemangel ist laut dem Arbeitsamt, wenn die Stelle einfach eine gewisse Zeit nicht besetzt werden konnte.
Dann fließt das in den Fachkräftemangel ein.
Wenn die Stelle einfach nur Kacke ist, ja, total unattraktive Arbeitsumfeld, Unternehmen, schlechte Bezahlung, und das will keiner machen, dann bleibt die Stelle unbesetzt, dann ist das Fachkräftemangel.
Also, für einen Großteil der Stellen würde man Leute finden, wenn die Unternehmen eins von drei Dingen machen würden.
Sich selbst attraktiver, vielleicht sind sie es ja schon, sie schaffen es bloß nicht ordentlich darzustellen.
Oder sie scheißen die Leute mit Geld zu, das machen die wenigsten, dann findet man auch Leute.
Oder sie schrauben ihre Ansprüche ein bisschen runter.
Und so eine Kombination aus allen drei, ohne jetzt bei einem voll vorne mit dabei zu sein, wirkt oftmals schon Wunder.
Und außerdem muss in der heutigen Zeit kreativ werden, es reicht nicht mehr, als 0815-Klitsche eine 0815-Stellenanzeige zu schreiben.
So nach dem Motto, wir sind die Max GmbH, wir sind Marktführer im Bereich von Klopapierwicklern.
Wir suchen für unser dynamisches, agiles Team Verstärkung.
Wir bieten ein leistungsorientiertes, marktübliches Gehalt.
Da bin ich schon, wenn ich das schon lese, bin ich schon direkt so Resident Sleeper.
So nach den ersten zwei Sätzen, da lege ich unter dem Tisch, wenn ich das sehe.
Und darauf bewirbt sich heute auch keiner, weil du halt deutlich bessere Angebote links und rechts daneben hast.
Und man kann natürlich bessere Stellenanzeigen schreiben, oder aber man macht das, was ich auch letztens von einem Recruiter gehört habe.
Man geht aktiv auf die Leute zu, die zwar noch in einem Arbeitsverhältnis sind, und macht denen ein Angebot.
Weil viele, die in einem Arbeitsverhältnis sind, sind da nicht hundertprozentig glücklich.
Die sind halt da und denken sich, ja, ist ganz okay, ich mache hier so ein bisschen nach Vorschrift, kriege meine Kohle für.
Eigentlich finde ich es nicht so toll hier, aber ich bin auch zu faul mir was Neues zu suchen.
Und wenn du die ansprichst und machst denen ein Angebot, da sind viele bereit, sich das mal anzuhören.
Oder sich auch mal anzugucken und dann auch zu wechseln.
Viel mehr, als man denkt.
Die müssten sich halt Mühe geben.
Ja gut, weil wenn es scheiße...
Ja, das ist halt das Problem, die Angebote sind scheiße.
Dann bringt es auch nicht, wenn man die bekommt, sondern dann muss es sich nicht wundern, dass da keiner drauf eingeht.
Also für einen Großteil der offenen Stellen bin ich ziemlich sicher, würde man Leute noch finden, wenn man die attraktiver machen würde.
Ja, aber unterm Strich, natürlich haben wir sicherlich mehr offene Stellen als Leute an Fachkräften im IT-Sektor, die man braucht.
Aber es ist nicht so krass, wie es teilweise dargestellt wird.
Der Markt für Ausbildungsplätze war extrem hart.
Ja, die sind halt dämlich, ja.
Das habe ich auch im alten Unternehmen gemerkt, wo ich gearbeitet habe bis vor zweieinhalb Monaten.
Sagen wir mal drei Monate, wo ich bis vor drei Monaten gearbeitet habe.
Die finden keine Leute, die suchen händeringend IT-Leute.
Aber meinst du, die würden mal was ausbilden?
Die haben erst vor zwei oder drei Jahren gesagt, wir bilden jetzt nichts mehr aus.
Und jetzt wollen sie wieder und jetzt sagen sie angeblich, sie finden keine.
Was halt glatt gelogen ist, mit sie finden keine.
Das war wirklich glatt gelogen.
Ich habe den, also wirklich drei Ecken, den ich kenne.
Also quasi der Freund von der Tochter von der Freundin von meiner Mutter.
Also wirklich so 50 Ecken.
Der macht gerade eine Umschulung zum Fachinformatiker Systemintegration.
Und bei der Umschulung müssen die ein Praktikum machen.
Oder nee, kein Praktikum.
Die müssen ein dreiviertel Jahr Praxis im Betrieb machen.
Wo sie dann auch ihr Abschlussprojekt durchführen sollen.
Das habe ich unserer Abteilung vorgeschlagen, die bei uns für Nachwuchsförderung,
also mit bei uns manchmal beim alten Arbeitgeber,
für Nachwuchsförderung und Azubis zuständig ist.
Und das hat die überhaupt nicht gejuckt.
Die haben keinen Finger krumm gemacht.
Ich musste die wochenlang fragen, wie es denn jetzt endlich ist.
Und am Ende haben sie mir abgesagt.
Und ich vermute, sie haben mir am gleichen Tag abgesagt, wo ich nochmal nachgefragt habe.
Und ich vermute, sie haben einfach abgesagt, weil sie keinen Bock hatten, sich drum zu kümmern.
Sie haben mir nämlich mit der Begründung abgesagt,
leider hat sich keine Abteilung gefunden, die ihnen ein Dreivierteljahr nehmen würde.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie richtig gefragt haben.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie sich überhaupt damit beschäftigt haben.
Die hatten einfach keinen Bock.
Und weil ich das dritte Mal genervt habe,
oder über meinen Chef habe anfragen lassen,
haben sie sich gezwungen gefühlt zu antworten und haben gesagt, geht nicht.
Und dann müssen die sich echt nicht beschweren.
Die haben es nicht besser verdient.
Die sollen sich für 500k das Jahr irgendwelche externen Consultants kaufen.
Ja, anscheinend haben sie ja genug Geld.
Wenn die die einfachsten Sachen,
und wohlgemerkt, das sind Leute, die dafür bezahlt werden, die dafür da sind,
sich mit Nachwuchsförderungen zu beschäftigen.
Und die haben so extrem versagt und keinen Bock gehabt.
Das ist echter Wahnsinn.
Dann müssen sie einfach das Geld, dann müssen sie,
das müssen sie halt bezahlen jetzt dadurch.
Ja, und das habe ich nicht nur dort, wo ich früher gearbeitet habe, gemerkt.
Ja, irgendwie wollen viele Leute IT-Experten haben, aber keine ausbilden.
Was keinen Sinn ergibt.
Irgendjemand muss die Leute ausbilden.
Das funktioniert halt nicht ohne.
Okay, Tom, das hätte ich so nicht gesagt.
Also ich hätte es vielleicht gesagt, aber nicht so.
Ich hätte es irgendwie versucht, etwas kompatibler zu formatieren.
So aktuell ist man schon im Arbeitsverhältnis,
aber wenn man von Rekruten angeschrieben wird,
guckt man sich natürlich auch gute Angebote mal an.
Du hast nicht aktiv gesucht, aber du fandst das Angebot gut und hast dich deswegen gemeldet.
Also ich hätte es nicht so gesagt.
Ja, ist auch so.
Ist genau das, was ich gesagt habe.
Viele offenen Stellen bleiben unbesetzt, weil die eben unattraktiv sind.
Das kann ja unterschiedliche Gründe haben,
aber hauptsächlich wahrscheinlich das Gehalt.
Nicht nur, nicht nur, aber hauptsächlich das Gehalt.
Ey, ich habe es schon verstanden.
Nee, macht doch keinen Spaß.
C-Sharp ist einfach die viel, viel bessere, angenehmere Sprache als C++.
C++ ist in manchen Bereichen sinnvoll.
Dort gibt es oftmals auch nicht viele Alternativen.
Zum Beispiel hier Microcontroller programmieren und sowas.
Aber ansonsten C-Sharp ist einfach so angenehm
und C++ so eklig, dass die Sprachen sich ähnlich lesen.
Ist schon, eigentlich schon schlimm.
Die könnten nicht viel weiter auseinander sein.
Ob die nächsten Generationen immer dümmer werden, glaube ich nicht.
Ich meine, okay, die gucken TikTok und solche Geschichten.
Aber im Ernst, das hat die Generation vor uns über uns auch gesagt.
Ey, das glaube ich nicht.
Glaube nicht, dass sie dümmer werden.
Also, was sie auf jeden Fall haben, ist, was Technik angeht.
Was Technik angeht, hatte ich eigentlich früher gedacht,
sodass die Generation nach mir überhaupt keine Probleme mehr mit Technik haben wird.
Sprich, ich musste damals beispielsweise ein DSL-Modem anschließen,
weil man damals halt neu DSL hatte.
Ich war einer der Ersten hier in Hanau, die DSL hatten, tatsächlich.
Und das haben wir auch damals nur hingekriegt,
weil mein Vater tatsächlich Monate, das ist keine Übertreibung,
und monatelang täglich bei der Telekom angerufen hat.
Wir hatten irgendwann die direkte Durchwahl zum hessischen Telekom-Chef,
weil ich es mit dem DSL-Anschluss nicht hinbekommen habe.
So, und ich war einer der Ersten in Hanau, der DSL hatte.
Und damals musste man ein DSL-Modem anschließen,
dann noch mit Netzwerkkarte und PPOE-Treiber und sowas.
Und da musste ich mir damals, ich meine, ich war damals noch relativ jung,
16 oder 15, 15, 16 so.
Und da dachte ich mir so, ey, wisst ihr was?
Die Generation nach mir, die müssen da überhaupt nicht mehr lange überlegen,
die machen das im Schlaf.
Für die ist es einfach das Normalste der Welt, ein DSL-Modem anzustöpseln.
Und da muss ich sagen, da lag ich echt komplett falsch.
Die Generation jetzt nach mir, die hat ein ganz anderes Problem.
Bei mir war das Problem, das war neu.
Hatte noch keine Ahnung von.
Die Generation nach mir hat das Problem,
die ist einfach gewöhnt, dass das Scheiß-Instant funktioniert
und wenn es nicht funktioniert, blicken sie nicht mal durch,
warum es nicht funktioniert.
Die haben also genauso wenig Plan, wie die davor und viele aus meiner Generation.
Aber aus einem ganz anderen Grund.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, die werden nicht dümmer,
die haben einfach andere Voraussetzungen quasi.
Und die haben sicherlich auch genug Leute, die sich für IT interessieren
und für die es auch kein Problem ist, einen DSL-Modem anzuschließen.
Aber die sind per Default planlos aus anderen Gründen,
als meine Generation defaultmäßig planlos war.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Wie wurde das abgerechnet? Pauschal oder anhand des Jahresgehalts?
Wahrscheinlich Jahresgehalt.
Irgendwie drei Monate oder sowas.
Drei Monatsgehälter.
Ja, du musst dich nicht wundern, sobald dir das Thema C++ fällt,
dann ist Pepega-Time angesagt.
Du kannst dich doch auch privat damit beschäftigen und dich bewerben.
Ich meine, Elektriker ist jetzt zwar keine IT-Ausbildung,
aber ich denke, wenn sich ein Elektriker bewirbt mit IT-Skills,
das ist nicht allzu weit hergeholt.
Sind 60K für 10 Jahre Berufserfahrung mit Ausbildung okay?
In welchem Bereich? Also Region? Branche? Welcher Job? Welche Ausbildung?
XOV? XXHD? 360? No Scope?
Das musst du schon dabei schreiben.
Ansonsten würde ich pauschal sagen, nein, 60K mit 10 Jahren Berufserfahrung
ist ein bisschen wenig, aber es kommt auf die Region an,
auf den Job an und was genau.
Baden-Württemberg IT-System, Elektronik, IT-Communications.
Ja gut, weiß nicht in welchem Bereich, welcher Job das ist,
aber ich würde sagen, klingt ein bisschen wenig.
Also 60K für 10 Jahre Berufserfahrung ist schon ein bisschen mau.
Oje, mein Beileid.
Ja, ich sage es ja immer, Excel ist die IDE der Sekretärin.
Falls das nicht zu sexistisch ist, heutzutage zu sagen.
Also man könnte sagen, die IDE des Sekretärs und der Sekretärinnen.
Oder wie auch immer man das ganz korrekt sagt.
Aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Also Excel ist die IDE der BWL-Noobs.
In welcher Programmiersprache sollte man sich weiterbilden,
um beliebt auf dem Arbeitsmarkt zu sein? Kobol.
Wenn du was sicheres haben willst.
Nee, ernsthaft, Kobol nicht.
Kobol ist was, wenn du Dinger maintainen willst, die 60 Jahre alt sind.
Okay, weißt du was das Beste ist?
Guck dir die aktuelle Stackoverflow-Umfrage an, da wird genau das beantwortet.
Also ich würde sagen, mit den Klassikern kannst du nicht verkehrt liegen.
Java, C-Sharp, JavaScript, Python, vielleicht ein bisschen Go.
Aber im Business- und Enterprise-Umfeld, Java, C-Sharp, JavaScript.
Ja, wahrscheinlich musst du dir das auch bezahlen, weil die sonst woanders hingegangen wären, oder?
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ich verstehe, dass das nicht einfach ist für Arbeitgeber, klar.
Gerade wenn du auch keine unendlich großen Budgets hast und eigentlich händeringend Leute brauchst,
aber jetzt auch nicht irgendwie Ultra-Geldreserven hast.
Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, das ist eklig.
Deswegen bin ich froh, dass ich bei einer Bank bin.
Die haben nahezu unendlich Geldreserven.
Alter, was ist mit euch los heute?
Warum wollt ihr alle Kubernetes-Cluster mit Seth selbst bauen?
Chetke, irgendjemand hat auch vorhin Leute gesucht.
Wollt ihr euch nicht zusammentun?
Dann könnt ihr das zusammen ein bisschen gegen die Wand fahren.
Geteiltes Leid ist halbes Leid, wisst ihr doch.
Okay, dann kamen die letztens noch mit der Idee, um die Ecke ein AI-Chatbot zu entwickeln.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel ich gerade gleichzeitig mache, aber macht das...
Ja, ist doch gut, ist doch gut.
Neue Sachen bauen macht extrem viel Spaß.
Was nicht so viel Spaß macht, ist, sich jahrelang um den Kram zu kümmern, den man eingeführt hat.
Also ihr müsst immer dran denken, alles was jetzt neu und shiny ist, ist in 3-4 Jahren auch mal alt und irgendwann hat Staub angesetzt.
Und das macht es sich unbedingt einfacher.
So verlockend es ist, immer neue Sachen, die klitzern, einzuführen in Massen,
ist es langfristig vielleicht auch ein bisschen mit der Problemverursacher.
Warum man nicht hinterherkommt, irgendwas auf die Reihe zu bekommen.
Sollte man sich immer mal überlegen.
Man, pauschal, ich kann viel erzählen, ich weiß ja nicht, was ihr da genau macht.
Kununu spammt mich voll, seitdem ich letztens eine Bewertung geschrieben habe.
Ich hatte mich ja beworben bei einem...
Soll ich anders sagen?
Ich hatte schon einen Arbeitsvertrag hier liegen, bei einem Unternehmen, wo mich einer quasi angeworben hat.
Aber ich bin dann woanders hingegangen, wo mich ein anderer Bekannter dazu angeworben hat.
Ist eigentlich lustig.
Ich musste gar nicht viel machen bei der Jobsuche.
Ich hatte übelst Glück.
Irgendwie sind die Leute die ganze Zeit immer auf mich zugekommen.
Und da habe ich eine Bewertung geschrieben über den Bewerbungsprozess bei Kununu,
über die Firma, wo ich mich beworben habe.
Aber wo ich dann abgesagt habe.
Und seitdem spammt mich Kununu zu mit, es gibt neue Bewertungen da und dafür.
Ah, wollen sie das hier nicht mal angucken?
Sind richtig aufdringlich.
Siehste?
Sag ich doch, als Elektriker ist gar nicht so weit hergeholt, dass Elektriker ein bisschen was mit IT am Hut hat.
Blendet mich aber die Seite zu sehr.
Ey, mir wurde letztens...
Ach, Dr. Pronups wieder am Start.
Ey, mir wurde letztens angeboten in einem coolen Softwareentwicklungsprojekt mitzuarbeiten.
Das sagen sie alle.
Vorher, dass sie cool sind.
Softwareentwicklungsprojekt mitzuarbeiten.
Bin dort eigentlich Werkstudent im Second Level Bereich.
Ich hab zugesagt, ja, würde ich auch machen.
Second Level, beziehungsweise generell Support ist doch abfuck.
Aber ich finde, dass ich jetzt für dieses Projekt zu unterbezahlt bin.
Soll ich das ansprechen?
Soll ich nach erfolgreichem Abschluss ansprechen?
Na, nach erfolgreichem Abschluss haben die ja gar kein Interesse, dir mehr zu bezahlen.
Könntest das...
Ja, gut, kann ich jetzt schwer einschätzen.
Weiß nicht, wie deine Vorgesetzten drauf sind.
Und wie lange das überhaupt noch geht.
Wie lange du noch Student bist.
Ich mein, ansprechen in der heutigen Zeit ist nie verkehrt.
Da geht immer was.
Und die müssen ja auch denken, dass du was kannst.
Sonst hätten sie dich ja nicht gefragt, ob du in das Projekt kommst.
Also, die Chancen würden da gar nicht mal so schlecht stehen.
Es ist ja auch schon ein Unterschied, ein bisschen rumgeklickt, Second Level Support zu machen.
Oder was zu entwickeln.
Meinst du?
Also, ich weiß es sowohl beim alten Arbeitgeber als auch beim neuen.
Nicht nur Seniorstellen sind teilweise monatelang offen.
Oder bei meinem alten sogar Jahre.
Das sind keine Seniorstellen.
Und das ist jetzt auch der alte Arbeitgeber, es ist kein unbekannter Laden.
Also, ich würde sagen, das zieht sich so durch.
Ich mein, in der Summe gibt es hiervon natürlich noch weniger als davon.
Das ist halt klar.
Aber ich glaube, Mangel gibt es überall.
Nick, dankeschön für den Sub.
Der Wert ist, dass man einen Azubi hat, der was kann.
In einem Bereich, wo man halt dringend Leute braucht.
Also, ich würde sagen, der Aufwand lohnt sich schon, Leute aufzubilden.
Schon mal was von streikenden ITlern gehört.
Wenn von den Admins 1-2 Wochen die Sommer nicht gewesen wären...
Ehrlich gesagt, fällt mir kein Fall ein, wo Leute mal wirklich gestreikt hätten.
Also, mir ist kein IT-Streik bekannt.
Es ist aber da auch, ehrlich gesagt, gar nicht notwendig.
Weil, wenn die dir nicht mehr Geld geben und du schon so weit bist, dass du sogar streiken würdest,
dann gehst du einfach woanders hin.
Hast wahrscheinlich einen besseren Job und mehr Geld.
Okay, also.
Master Informatik an der Fachhochschule.
Vier Jahre davon als Werkstudent gearbeitet,
Ja gut, wahrscheinlich werden sie dir sagen, das ist keine Berufserfahrung.
Was es ja irgendwo schon ist.
Aber das ist ähnlich wie, die Ausbildung ist keine Berufserfahrung.
Was sie eigentlich auch ist, aber okay.
Vier Jahre davon als Werkstudent in Paris.
Kam drei Firmen.
Def.
Obs.
Java.
Docker.
Unifol.
Deep-Learning-Expertise zum Beispiel.
Versuche beides zu verbinden.
Jetzt in einem Unternehmen in Hamburg.
Biometrie.
Angestellt als IA.
Integrator.
Systemmanager.
Entwickler.
Computerwisser.
Modeller.
Streamer.
Schätzgehalt.
Na ja gut.
Das ist wahrscheinlich nix, wo du 0815 jemanden kriegst.
Boah, das ist schwer zu sagen.
Keine Ahnung.
Also, ich persönlich würde jetzt wahrscheinlich was recht hohes sagen, aber wenn du das schreibst,
willst du wahrscheinlich sagen, es ist viel zu wenig dafür.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Achttausend.
Ich würde tendenziell sogar ein bisschen mehr schätzen, aber ich gehe davon aus, wenn
du das schreibst, muss es wahrscheinlich weniger sein.
Ich sage 80k.
Gono.
Ne, Kono.
Und?
Was gibt's?
Kommt weiter unten.
Okay.
65k.
Ansonsten teile ich es einfach immer in der Mitte und wir haben es relativ schnell gefunden.
Wenn es hier Leute im Chat gibt, die Linux-Admins oder DevOps-Leute auf Junior-Niveau in ihrem
Unternehmen suchen.
Gerne per PN.
Ja.
Haben wir bestimmt.
Also, Chat-Gil, wir machen jetzt Woblos Jobbörse.
Also, wenn ihr Linux-Admins sucht, let's go.
DarkSide ist auf der Suche.
DarkSide kann ich auch sagen, der ist total oft hier und ich glaube, der hat auch schon
die einen oder anderen schlauen Sachen im Chat gepostet.
Also, ich denke, das sollte genug Bewerbungsgrundlage sein.
Twitch-PN im Jobinterview.
Voll geil.
Was für einen Cut verlangst du?
Prime-Subscriptions.
Das kann ich dir nicht mehr sagen, um was es ging.
Ich bin jetzt erst, ich bin 10 Minuten hinten dran im Chat.
Keine Ahnung.
In unserer Generation sind auch nicht viele technikaffin.
Nur wir.
Und wir wissen es halt auch.
Ich würde sogar sagen, dass potenziell in der jungen Generation mehr technikaffin sind
als in unserer.
Ich sag jetzt einfach mal unserer.
Ich bin 1984 geboren.
Ja, aber es werden halt auch unglaublich viele IT-Leute gebraucht.
Kennt sich wer mit OpenCV aus?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Wir haben zwar schon ein paar Sachen im Stream gemacht.
Ich überlege gerade, was das war.
Was haben wir nochmal mit OpenCV?
Archiv.
OpenCV.
Motion Detection mit OpenCV.
Chatge, woran liegt denn das, dass im Archiv manche, manche Sachen nicht drin sind?
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich die Worts gelöscht habe.
Weil ich da irgendwas geleakt habe.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich an mir.
Ja.
Gut.
Heißt ja nicht, dass jeder Ahnung von Technik hat.
Aber im Durchschnitt würde ich sagen, interessieren sich heute schon mehr als früher.
Weitkei.
Danke für den Prime-Sub.
Der Obstkorb, Leute.
Der Obstkorb und spannende Team-Events.
Seid ihr da auch so scharf drauf wie ich?
Jantari, danke für den Sub.
Spannende Team-Events.
Ist für mich immer der Bewerbungsgrund schlechthin.
Du bist letzter in der Presse und musst für meinen Chef gerade technische Dinge bewerten.
Moment.
Die Gehaltsverhandlung ist, wenn du willst.
Du musst jetzt nicht sagen, wir machen jetzt Gehaltsverhandlung und wenn es in fünf Minuten nicht passiert, kündige ich.
Man muss ja nicht übertreiben.
Aber Gehaltsverhandlung ist zeitnah, wenn du das willst.
Und nicht, wir können ja erst in einem halben Jahr drüber reden.
Das ist typische Hinhaltetaktik.
Das ist Blödsinn.
Wenn du sagst, wir müssen uns mal über meine Gehaltssituation unterhalten,
dann hat dein Chef gefälligst dafür zu sorgen, dass innerhalb der nächsten, sagen wir mal, 14 Tage, da ein Termin stattfindet.
Äh, nee.
Ist das...
Und ja, es ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht, dich umzugucken.
Es ist auf jeden Fall, wie ich vorhin schon mehrfach im Stream gesagt habe,
es schadet nie, links und rechts zu gucken, weil dann weißt du, was du wert bist.
Und du kannst entspannt wie sonst was in irgendwelche Bewerbungssachen reingehen,
weil du hast ja eh schon noch einen Job in der Tasche.
Und wenn du was Gutes findest, kannst du abhauen.
Also guck dich auf jeden Fall ein bisschen links und rechts um.
Ja, du musst jetzt nicht den super Bewerbungsmarathon machen,
aber guck dir mal in deiner Nähe an, was es für Stellen gibt.
Vielleicht ist da was Cooles dabei.
Vielleicht ergibt sich ja auch irgendwas.
Und du kannst ein bisschen Vorstellungsgespräche üben.
Kannst dir eine gute Bewerbung erstellen.
Machst dir einen ordentlichen Lebenslauf.
Listest deine Skills auf in einer Art und Weise, wie das gut ankommt.
Und dann machst du mal die ein oder anderen Vorstellungsgespräche mit.
Und tastest dich ein bisschen ran.
Und dann weißt du im Endeffekt unterm Strich auch, was du verlangen kannst.
Und vielleicht ist was richtig Gutes dabei und du sagst, scheiß drauf, ich bin eh weg.
Ausbildung als Physiotherapeut.
Seit zwei Jahren ausgerechnet.
Lebe auf dem Land in NDS.
Ich weiß nicht, was NDS ist.
Nintendo DS?
Norddeutschland?
Süd?
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Was ist NDS?
Haupt...
Ach, Niedersachsen.
Okay.
Ist das im Osten?
Im Osten sind die Gehälter ja leider ein bisschen pp-ger.
Hauptaufgaben, Administration, Netzwerk und Feierwahl in einer internen Schule.
Administration, Netzwerk und Feierwahl in einer internen IT 56K.
Früher hätte ich mir da ein Modem drunter vorgestellt und kein Gehalt.
Wie ist da deine Einschätzung?
Ich kann also zu Gehälter im Osten und nachdem ich die Branche auch nicht...
Kann ich schwer was sagen.
Also, es klingt für den Osten und für quasi mehr oder weniger noch recht frisch ausgelernt eigentlich ganz okay.
Ist Niedersachsen nicht Osten?
Chat, woher soll ich das denn wissen?
Ich hab von so geografischen Sachen keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich doch nicht.
Was würdest du sagen, was einen Tieradministrator als Anfangsgehalt verlangen sollte?
Also, ich kann dir was sagen, aber es ist abhängig davon, welche Branche und welche Region und sowas natürlich immer.
Also, mein Einstiegsgehalt war 33.500 und das ist 15 Jahre her.
Naja, nicht ganz.
Ist schon ne Weile her.
Oder 13 Jahre her.
So, und wenn man das jetzt hochrechnet, würde ich sagen, so 45k ist schon okay.
40 bis 45k sollte es schon sein, drunter nicht.
So ungefähr als Hausnummer.
Ehrlich gesagt bin ich der Meinung, dass das in der heutigen Zeit sogar eher noch zu wenig ist.
Weil es einfach an allen Ecken und Enden fehlt.
Ne, das war schon Euro.
Das war schon Euro.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, darf ruhig auch noch mehr sein.
In der heutigen Zeit ist das alles möglich.
Es kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an, auf Region, Branche und Berufserfahrung.
Also 60k sind okay, je nachdem, was die Rahmenbedingungen sind.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, gerade in der aktuellen Lage, es darf im IT-Bereich durchaus auch in, wie soll man es nennen, in höhere Sphären gehen.
Weil jetzt ist die Zeit, wo man das halt mal ausnutzen kann.
Und wäre halt blöd, wenn man es nicht macht.
Ne, das ist nicht sein Einstiegsgehalt.
Tom hat den Job gewechselt.
Glaube ich.
Als Einstiegsgehalt wäre das vollkommen in Ordnung.
Also da würde ich mich nicht beschweren.
Das stimmt.
Du musst halt was können.
Ne, das ist ja mit knapp 8 Jahren Erfahrung.
Wenn du mit 60k einsteigst und nichts auf die Reihe kriegst, ist halt die Frage, warum sollten sie denn mehr bezahlen.
Also nur weil IT an deinem Jobtitel dran steht, heißt ja nicht zwangsläufig, dass sie dich mit Geld überhäufen müssen.
Du musst schon noch was auf die Reihe kriegen.
Ja, Ami-Gehälter sind eh krass, was das angeht.
Klingt auch gut.
Als Einstieg klingt das doch erstmal nicht verkehrt.
Also wer das sagt, das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Also wenn da ab und zu mal der ein oder andere Jobwechsel draufsteht, ist das nicht verkehrt.
Finde ich auch nicht schlimm.
Wenn ich jetzt natürlich jemand habe, der irgendwie jedes Jahr woanders ist und das schon seit irgendwie einer längeren Zeit,
dann würde ich mich halt auch fragen, lohnt es sich den einzuarbeiten, wenn er im Jahr wieder weg ist.
Wenn ich halt, ich meine Cidern sind wirklich nachvollziehbare Gründe.
Ja, dann ist es was anderes.
Aber wenn irgendjemand mal die letzten 10 Jahre 3-4 mal den Job gewechselt hat,
warum nicht?
Aber das Beste ist, wenn ihr mehr Gehalt wollt, erstmal euch umgucken, während ihr noch safe den anderen Job habt.
Das ist einfach viel angenehmer und einfacher.
Und entweder ergibt sich was Gutes und ihr haut einfach ab, oder euer alter Arbeitgeber,
wenn ihr dann wisst, was ihr so wert seid, haut nochmal ein bisschen was drauf.
Wobei ich sagen würde, rein für das Geld würde ich nicht bleiben.
Also wenn ich ein gutes, anderes Angebot hätte, mit dem ich mir einig wäre,
und nur mit, ich hau jetzt ab, Drohung, man mehr Geld bekommt,
dann würde ich mir überlegen, ob ich das mache.
Ganz ehrlich, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Weil die Probleme, die einen dazu getrieben haben, sich was anderes zu suchen,
die sind ja immer noch da.
Und es gibt sogar, glaube ich, eine Statistik dazu,
dass Leute, die sich vom Gehalt haben überzeugen lassen, doch noch da zu bleiben,
im Durchschnitt, oder ich weiß es nicht, wie es genau war,
aber im Schnitt wohl auch maximal nur noch ein halbes oder Jahr da bleiben und dann doch wechseln.
Also höchstwahrscheinlich ändert das am Ausgang auch nichts.
Natürlich, wenn es super krass viel mehr Geld gibt,
Warum nicht? Letztendlich gehen wir alle arbeiten, um Geld zu verdienen.
Also wenn ihr irgendwo sucht, ihr findet einen neuen Job, mit was weiß ich,
80k und euer alter Arbeitgeber sagt dann,
ach ja, wir bezahlen wieder 150k, oder was auch immer,
einfach mal zusammen gesponnen jetzt.
Natürlich, da kann man auch sagen, ja, du darfst nicht mehr arbeiten,
du musst jetzt nicht mehr arbeiten, du kannst nicht mehr arbeiten,
dann kannst du nicht mehr arbeiten, dann kannst du nicht mehr arbeiten,
natürlich, da kann man auch sagen, ja, da bleibe ich natürlich da,
und dann ist man vielleicht auch ein bisschen toleranter gegenüber den Sachen,
die einem auf den Sack gehen, weil man sich denkt, ey, ist mir egal,
ich werde mir nichts mit Geld zugeschissen.
Ist ja auch okay, kann man ja auch machen.
Aber in der Regel geht es ja hier nicht um, wir bezahlen dir einfach mal das Doppelte,
sondern, ja, wir bezahlen dir dann auch ordentlich was mehr
und dann sind die Leute zu faul, den eigentlich richtigen Schritt zu gehen
und zu sagen, ey, ich habe jetzt eigentlich was gefunden,
was besser ist und was auch noch gut bezahlt, ich haue jetzt ab
und die Probleme bleiben halt weiterhin bestehen,
die einem in den letzten Jahren schon auf den Keks gegangen sind
und einen dazu gebracht haben.
Ja, also insofern ist wahrscheinlich, wenn man ein gutes Angebot findet,
was insgesamt einem einfach mehr zusagt, also aus der Gesamtkombination,
aus Vorteilen, Gehalt und allem drum und dran,
wenn einem das Gesamtpaket einfach mehr zusagt als beim Alten,
dann ist wahrscheinlich die beste Wahl jetzt abzuhauen.
Genau, deswegen, Donnergrat, deswegen sage ich ja Gesamtpaket.
Ich meine, wir sollten uns nichts hier irgendwie einreden,
Gehalt ist trotzdem der größte Faktor im Gesamtpaket, selbstverständlich.
Aber nicht alles.
Also mal unabhängig jetzt von der Arbeit, der Atmosphäre,
den Teams, den Aufgaben und so an sich,
gibt es natürlich auch noch Vorteile, die geldwert sind.
Ja, zum Beispiel Kinderbetreuung.
Parkplätze und sowas.
Mag jetzt erstmal naheliegen klingen, aber es spart einfach extrem viel Zeit,
wenn ihr die Kinder nicht in den Kindergarten fahren müsst,
dann auf die Arbeit, sondern die mitnehmen könnt auf die Arbeit
und in der Kinderbetreuung abgeben und wieder mit heim.
Das spart Geld, das spart Zeit, das spart Nerven.
Und wenn ihr dann sogar noch dort parken könnt.
Also das sind schon durchaus Sachen, die man anrechnen muss.
Aber ich sag das nur so, weil ich hab letztens erfahren,
dass dort, wo ich jetzt arbeite, die haben tatsächlich Kinderbetreuung.
Hunde im Büro mag ich nicht.
Hatten wir beim Provider, hatten wir einen Hund im Büro.
Hat mir nicht gefallen.
Wie man am besten mit Linux anfangen kann?
Ja, vm installieren und als tägliches Arbeitssystem benutzen.
Für alles mögliche.
Halt für Sachen, wo es nicht Windows sein muss.
Sprich, wenn du Spiele machen willst, Videos streamen willst,
dann natürlich von Windows aus.
Aber mach alltägliche Sachen unter Linux.
Serve im Internet unter Linux.
Mach irgendwelche täglichen Administrationssachen unter Linux.
Dadurch, dass du das als Betriebssystem verwendest,
tagtäglich mehrere Stunden, lernst du automatisch was.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was am besten ist für Entwickler.
Am besten für Entwickler ist ein Job, der einem gefällt
und ordentlich Kohle bezahlt.
Also ich war in einem Unternehmen mit Tarifvertrag
und jetzt bin ich in einem, auch mit Tarifvertrag,
aber mein, wie nennt man das?
Ein Vertrag ist ohne Tarifvertrag.
Also, das sagt erstmal nichts aus.
Tarifvertrag ist natürlich nice,
wenn man automatisch alle paar Jahre mehr Geld kriegt.
Außertarif, genau das Wort hat mir gefehlt, ja.
Außertariflich, das hat mir gefehlt, das Wort.
Ja, das meinte ich.
Ich mein, warum nicht?
Warum sollte ich sagen, nein, aber ich will unbedingt,
wenn ich einfach so viel mehr Kohle kriege,
soll mir das recht sein?
Weiß nicht, hab ich nicht gesagt.
Vier Prozent, ist ja nix.
Da hast du ja die letzten zwei Jahre schon massig Verlust gemacht.
Ganz ehrlich, Frankfurt, du hast alle Möglichkeiten.
Also ich mein, es sei denn, du verdienst schon 180k im Jahr
oder was auch immer du bisher verdient hast,
dann würde ich sagen, okay, dann ist vier Prozent mehr trotzdem nice.
Aber vermute ich jetzt mal nicht.
In Frankfurt hast du alle Möglichkeiten.
Wo du hinspuckst, ist irgendein IT-Dienstleister,
ein Rechenzentrum oder Finanzdienstleister,
eine Finanzbranche, was die Leute suchen.
Gar nicht, bloß nicht.
Ich glaub, das Schlimmste, was wir im Stream gemacht haben, war mal,
kann sich auch noch einer dran erinnern, Kobol.
Das war grausam, Alter.
Beste Schriftart dafür, oder?
Ja.
Ging mir ähnlich.
Guckt mal, Leute, wenn ihr meine Videos verfolgt habt,
vielleicht auf YouTube,
ich hab immer gesagt, ich bleib da wahrscheinlich.
Das hat erst die letzten zwei Jahre angefangen,
wo ich immer mehr mit dem Gedanken gespielt hab, abzuhauen.
Und jetzt bin ich wo gelandet,
ich mein, ich bin jetzt zweieinhalb Monate, drei Monate da,
aber ich denke nicht, dass sich das großartig noch ändern wird,
wo ich froh bin, dass ich das gemacht hab.
Und nicht nur wegen Stonks und Money, sondern insgesamt.
Der Umgang da mit den Leuten ist auch viel angenehmer.
Nicht so viel Boomer-Gelaber den ganzen Tag.
Und Leute, die auf den Keks gehen wollen.
Glaubt mir, den eigenen Kubernetes-Cluster betreiben ist keine gute Idee.
Wenn ihr nicht drei, vier Leute habt,
die schon langjährig Kubernetes-Erfahrung haben,
habt,
haben, habt, weiß auch immer, ihr weißt, was ich mein,
sucht euch einen Cloud-Anbieter und hostet das Ding da.
Es muss nicht Azure sein, es muss nicht Google oder AWS sein.
Gibt auch deutlich günstigere Anbieter.
DigitalOcean zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Die Idee ist kacke.
Ich hab's heute im Stream auch schon öfters gesagt.
Ich hab mich da auch,
ich hab mich da auch am Anfang des Streams
ein bisschen detaillierter dazu ausgelassen,
wo da die Probleme sind.
Das muss ich jetzt nicht nochmal alles erzählen,
ich muss gleich ins Bett.
Wir machen demnächst hier Jobvermittlung auf Twitch, Leute.
Ich weiß, hier gucken Leute zu,
die auch in, wie nennt man das, Personalverantwortung sind.
Ja, ich glaub, so nennt man das ja.
Und wir gucken, wir haben auch genug Leute,
die zugucken, die Jobs, Jobangebote,
Jobangeboten aufgeschlossen gegenüberstehen.
Wir machen demnächst quasi so eine,
so eine Art Bauer sucht Frau auf Twitch für IT-Jobs.
Tinder, ja.
Dizzy.
Dizzy Tinder.
Und ich, und ich kann damit auch noch Geld verdienen.
Ich bring dann das Wobbler Certified raus.
Gibt's dann so ein Zertifikat.
Ja, Tari, danke für den Sub.
Kannst du eine Informatikausbildung empfehlen,
wenn man keine Programmiersprachen spricht,
aber generelles Interesse an Digital Infrastruktur
und dem zukunftssicheren, so wie wir sagen.
Naja, was spricht dagegen dich einfach,
wenn dich Programmieren interessiert,
dich mal so damit zu beschäftigen?
Mal gucken, ob das auch was für dich ist.
Ansonsten, vor der Ausbildung,
ich mein, es gibt zwar neben Fachinformatiker,
Systemintegration und Fachinformatiker,
Anwendungsentwicklung jetzt noch drei neue
Fachinformatikerberufe.
Wie verbreitet die sind, weiß ich nicht.
Aber das sind eigentlich die zwei relevanten Ausbildungen.
Und ich, ich persönlich würde jetzt
von einem Azubi nicht erwarten,
dass der schon alles Mögliche kann,
wenn er neu anfängt.
Wichtig für mich wäre, dass es jemand ist,
der sich dafür interessiert,
und der, der sich da auch,
der was lernen will.
Und dann kann er auch Programmieren
und alles drumherum, was dazugehört,
in der Ausbildung lernen.
Aber du musst halt erstmal rauskriegen,
ob das prinzipiell was für dich ist.
Wurzelzirpel, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich stand da heute übrigens in der Eisdiele
vor einem, vor einer sehr schwierigen Entscheidung.
Und zwar, ich kann euch das Bild
gerade nicht zeigen,
es gab dort Eis zur Auswahl.
Und zwar gab es einmal
Spider-Man-Eis,
Eis-Königin-Eis,
oder Pepper-Wutz-Eis.
Ich wusste bis vorhin gar nicht,
was Pepper-Wutz ist.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was Pepper-Wutz ist?
Das ist anscheinend sowas wie Hello Kitty,
bloß bisschen neuer.
Ähm, ja.
Da wusste ich gar nicht, was ich nehmen soll.
Eins geiler als das andere.
Ja, das Schwein, genau.
Pepper-Wutz ist in China verboten,
ich dachte, das ist Winnie-Pooh.
Oder auch, auch alles verboten.
Warum nicht alle drei?
Nee, ich hab dann tatsächlich
klassisch, klassisch Eis genommen.
Nichts von den drei.
Box-Subscription hier.
Ja, da wird damnächst gecheckt,
in der Bewerbung,
ob man Wubbler-Subscriber ist.
Wubbler-Subscriber skippen automatisch
die erste Bewerbungsrunde
und werden direkt zum
Vorstellungsgespräch eingeladen.
Aber ich hab Vorstellungsgespräch gelesen.
Äh.
Ehrlich gesagt würde ich schon
während des Gesprächs
mal so ne
so ne Tendenz erwarten.
Beziehungsweise,
was jetzt genau passieren soll.
Also wenn einer, also wenn ein Chef
in nem, in nem, in nem Gespräch sagt
so nach dem Motto,
ja, mal gucken, was, was wir machen können,
wir sagen dir dann Bescheid,
dann wird's wahrscheinlich nie was.
Also bei sowas sollte immer rauskommen
so nach dem Motto, ja, ich kümmere mich drum.
Von einem Chef, weil das ist sein Job,
dafür ist er unter anderem mit da.
Also nächste Woche Rücksprache
hier mit unserem Abteilungsleiter.
Da werden wir das ansprechen,
wir gehen jetzt mal mit was weiß ich
so und so viel mehr ins Rennen
und ich sag dir dann nächste Woche,
was rausgekommen ist.
So, so, so würde ich das erwarten
in der Richtung.
Ja, nice.
Also wie weit ich hinten dran bin.
Über welche Plattform hast du deine Stellen gefunden?
Über gar keine Plattform.
Mich hat, ähm, also,
lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Ähm, Verträge bekommen.
Und zwar,
bei beiden Fällen wurde ich
angesprochen
von Leuten,
die ich kannte von früher,
die jetzt dort arbeiten.
Bei den einen hatte ich ja schon
den Vertrag hier liegen,
wo ich dann Vorstellungsgespräch
bei den anderen hatte und die hatten
einfach ein besseres Gesamtpaket
und dann bin ich dahin.
Da musste ich absagen,
das war mir echt ein bisschen peinlich
Leute, ich schaff den Chat nicht mehr,
bis ich ins Bett muss.
Ich bin zu weit hinten dran,
ich muss jetzt pennen.
Ich bin schon seit 30 Minuten hinten dran.
Wenn es was ganz Wichtiges ist,
was ich vergessen hab, merkt es euch
und wir besprechen es im nächsten Stream.
Ich hau jetzt ab.
Bis denn,
CU, macht's gut.